this one here
welcome to the Fish and Game committee
everybody
um
if you don't know me I am representative
James Spillane and next to me is Jeff
goli and representative goalie and he's
the vice chair and then to my left is uh
the clerk representative Reed
uh we're gonna start with the clerk uh
calling a role just to get to know the
names and at that time I'd like you to
sort of introduce yourself as well
because we have the the department here
to do an orientation with us where
they're going to introduce all their
members from the fish and game
department and I think it would be nice
for them to also get to know who you are
so we'll start that way and I'll turn it
over
representative goalie
here and for the uh representative Jeff
Coley in my 12th term representing
Hillsboro 21 which is Manchester Ward
one
uh in my 12 years here I have served as
chair of the executive Department's
Administration committee as well as
chair of the labor committee I also
co-chair the legislative Sportsman's
caucus as well as I was just elected
current president of the National
Assembly of Sportsman's caucuses which
is caucuses from across the country all
50 states that have the interest of
sports men and women
so thank you for
being here today
representative Khan appears absent
representative Smith
my name is Jonathan Smith this was my
second term I represent Ossipee Carroll
County District 5. thank you
thank you representative Koval
thank you my name is Jim cofald I
represent Hillsborough District 32
Wilton Temple and New Ipswich this is my
second term and I also sit on Health and
Human Services and the special committee
on commissions
thank you representative Tudor
representative Tudor um
Rockingham one Northwood Nottingham this
is my second term
thank you representative Bartlett
uh representative barley district one
Nottingham northward first term
thank you representative Brown
uh good morning Carol Brown
from Bristol New Hampshire I am the
representative for Grafton District 10.
I have some history with fish and game I
work for the Department of Environmental
Services for 30 years uh we're closely
on the coastal program and oil spill
contingency response and oil Wildlife
Rehabilitation plan and work closely
with the chief of marine fisheries and
others at Fish and Game in the oils pool
preparedness so have a close connection
with the coast protecting the coastal
area and the Great Bay in particular
thank you thank you representative
cocoran
no but not present representative
nutting
I'm representative Zach nothing
um I'm from Winchester District 11 and
this is my first term
thank you representative Willett
Mike Willette from Colebrook
representing co-auth District 3 which is
uh West Stewartstown Colebrook and
Columbia
thank you representative Harvey
absent
uh representative Reed is me my name is
Ellen Reed I represent Newmarket and new
Fields that's Rockingham 10. this is my
fourth term and my fourth term on this
committee I in that duration this is my
second term as Clerk and in that
duration I have worked I think I can
safely say extensively on conservation
issues having won awards from Humane
Society and voices of wildlife for my
work thank you representative Ford
uh Demond Ford Hillsborough 40 which is
Manchester's Awards 1 3 10 11 and 12.
um this is my first term and first time
on this amazing committee thank you
representative Fox
Lauren Fox this is my first term
representing Bedford uh one of seven
representatives in the town of Bedford
thank you representative Ming
hi Ben Ming first term State Rep
representing Hillsborough 35
um Hollis thank you representative
Morton
hi Jennifer Morton representing Amherst
District 34 Hillsborough and this is my
first term
thank you representative page
David page I represent Carol one Conway
the town of Conway
um this is my first term as well a lot
of first termers
um and I also serve on the special
committee on Child Care thank you
representative pair
hello I'm Gail pair I'm from Dover I
represent district 16 which is Ward 3 in
Dover and it's my first term
thank you representative rosener
my name is James Rosner I represent
Merrimack 22. this is my first term
thank you and cheerspelling
thank you madam clerk I am
representative Spillane I represent uh
Rockingham 2 which is Deerfield Candia
and Auburn now since we redistricted
um and I am on my fifth term and all of
which I've spent here on this committee
is my first term as chair
and thank you all for introducing
yourselves I know that representative
Harvey's around somewhere I've seen her
but we may have other absences that I
wasn't aware of I will now uh turn our
meeting over to the fish and game
department to introduce themselves and
give us their presentation thank you
thank you very much chairman spleen and
I would like to thank the committee for
the opportunity to be here today
um and to talk about the New Hampshire
Fish and Game department my name is
Scott Mason I'm the executive director
of the department
New Hampshire fishing game was
established way back in June 30th 1865.
we celebrated our 150th uh birthday not
too long ago
we were reorganized in 1935 under its
current format so
we've
we've been
um been here for a while there shall be
um
the legislation that that uh did the
reorganize the department there shall be
a fish and game department under a
commission to be known as the fish and
game department
um we are a little different than most
State departments we have a let me use
the term active commission
um our commission has 11 members
representing each each of the 10
counties and the 11th represents the
Tidewater communities
their duty is to represent the citizens
of New Hampshire to be stewards of the
Fish Wildlife and Marine Resources of
the State of New Hampshire and to set
the general policy for conservation of
wildlife development funding and
implementation of a strategic plan for
the Department
accusation acquisition and development
of public access to lands and water for
recreational use consistent with New
Hampshire law
conservation education and building
support for departmental programs
establishing
uh positions on proposed legislation and
affect the department that that affect
the Department Wildlife and Marine
Resources
um
so that our commission ends up being the
folks that will set our our positions on
all of our legislation
um and it makes it you know we have to
jump through a few extra hoops and what
other departments do because we have to
have a public meeting within our
department with the commission to set
set our position
so we appreciate any uh a little extra
notice on any uh legislative proposals
the executive director has the
responsibility of supervision of
employees and all activities and
functions of the department and to
enforce all provisions of the state laws
related to Fish Wildlife and Marine
Resources
also has the duty to develop and
implement the budget for the Department
our mission statement as Guardians of
the state Fish Wildlife and Marine
Resources the New Hampshire Fish and
Game department works and particip in
partnership with the public
to conserve manage and protect these
resources and their habitats inform and
educate the public about these resources
and provide the public with
opportunities to use and appreciate
these resources
it would be impossible for us to do our
job without the support of the public
and the citizens of the State of New
Hampshire
um
not just the sportsmen that are out in
the field
participating in in and working with us
on game management but also just the
citizens that you know make their their
land available for for sportsmen also
share their land with the wild species
that that roam the woods I'm sure over
your tenure here you will hear
um not not everybody enjoys enjoys all
aspects of wildlife
um and I'm sure you'll hear testimony to
that uh over your course of time here
but without their support we would never
be able to do the do our job
we are a self-funded department Hunters
Anglers Wildlife enthusiasts hikers ohrv
Riders all help to support the
department some buy licenses some buy
registrations hike safe cards some
through donations our non-game program
is runoff donations provided to the
department to support their programs
most people do not understand the
commitment that Sportsmen and women make
to fish and wildlife conservation
without their generous support through
licensed purchases and the pain of
federal excise tax on items associated
with hunting and fishing conservation as
we know it today would not exist
in 2021 New Hampshire hunters and
Anglers purchased a little over 11.6
million dollars in New Hampshire
licenses
they also the department received 3.1
million in Dingle Johnson funding which
is federal funding and 3.5 million in
Pittman Robinson funding the sources on
both of these fundings are excise taxes
that Sportsmen and women pay when they
buy guns ammunition
fishing tackle anything to do with
hunting and fishing and that's really
the source of the the bulk of the money
that we we receive
um
we also receive we we use some of the
state license fees that we receive to
leverage and receive an additional one
uh a little over 1.1 million dollars
from NOAA to run our marine programs
we have seven divisions today I have all
my divisions here I'd like to take a
minute and introduce each division Chief
business division is Kathy Labonte
yeah okay
our business division deals with the
overall business management of the
department so if you have money
questions she's the lady with the
answers
ohrv registrations license sales and and
Fleet Management she also does is in
charge of doing the mechanic work around
around our headquarters
facilities lands division right now that
Chief's position is open so if anybody
knows a good engineer that they'd like
to recommend we are shopping but today I
have Garrett grass Camp representing
that division Garrett's in charge of our
boat access program
so this division uh maintains our
facilities does the maintenance on our
facilities and our construction internal
construction projects that we do they
also run our boat access program
Inland Fisheries I have Chief Diane
Timmins with us today
that that division is in charge of fish
management uh Fisheries habitat and also
our Hatchery program
um law enforcement division today I have
Colonel Jordan
he uh that division has conservation
offices responsibilities on search and
rescue
um
ohrv education and enforcement
our Marine Division today I have Chief
Sherry Patterson
that division Marine Resource Management
Great Bay National Estuary research
reserve and Great Bay Discovery Center
uh with me today uh our public I'm sorry
our Wildlife division uh Dan Bergeron is
the chief he is at a senate hearing
today testifying so in his stay we have
um our game our game management uh Chief
and his name is Andrew Timmons
uh he's in charge of the game programs
we also have a non-game programs and
wildlife habitat programs and last but
not least I have our public affairs
division Nicola Whitley uh
uh she that division deals with
conservation communication a
conservation education aquatic education
Hunter's Ed and also runs our Brook
hunter's ed um Education Center
and with that I'll turn it over to my
Chiefs and we'll start with Kathy
thank you director
being here or come up here please come
up to the mic so we can all hear you
the director indicated I am Kathy
Labonte and I have been with the
Department almost 20 years since August
of 2003 and representative Brown I
worked with you over at DES you may
remember me as Kathy Partridge over
there
as the chief of the business Division I
have 12 full-time positions including me
and we have three very distinct
functions within the business division
we have the licensing ohrv registrations
all accounting business and financial
functions as well as Fleet Management
the division's responsibilities include
I have five staff who are dedicated
working within the licensing and ohrv
registration section for the issuance of
all
uh for the sale of fishing and hunting
licenses stamps and permits we have
approximately 370 agents throughout the
state some of those are duplicate agents
they sell both ohrv and hunting and
fishing licenses and we provide all of
the accounting for and customer support
in addition to that we have business
functions including processing of all
accounts payable accounts receivable
cash management banking as well as
purchasing for all goods and services
we oversee 55 plus federal grants we do
the tracking and reporting of
approximately seven to nine million
dollars of income annually from those
grants
in addition to other grants and other
agency income in addition to the recent
arpa funding which as you all are very
well aware has been a significant income
to the state of New Hampshire and a lot
of reporting that goes along with it
um all contracts governor and Council
and fiscal committee items come through
the business office and through me
we are also responsible for all shipping
and receiving services and mail services
for the entire department I also oversee
two full-time mechanics we have a
complete uh very large garage with full
service with it and we oversee at least
460 unique pieces of equipment that we
service including
trucks ATVs boats snowmobiles
motorcycles and various types of
trailers and miscellaneous construction
equipment
I myself work very closely with several
other state agencies including Das
treasury dncr Des among others
I oversee and have a hand in all of this
business activity plus I am solely
responsible for the preparation and
submission of the agency's biennial
budget
and with that I would entertain any
questions or if it's up to the chair to
hold questions until the end any
questions
representative Harvey can you tell me um
what kind of things
um the arbor funds were allowed to be
used for in the fish and game department
well we had uh several pots that came in
for the fish and game department we
purchased
um some critical equipment for law
enforcement including a couple of boats
I believe Colonel yep
and we paid for some computers
we also were issued but have not
received yet a 55 million dollar Arbor
allotment for a very large Hatchery
project
um we received two pots of arpa funding
through Des which the funds went through
des and we are a sub-recipient of that
one of those pots was one million
dollars for a hatchery feasibility study
with which all of those funds were
contracted out to a contractor to
provide a feasibility study on the
director could probably talk a little
better about that on what we can do with
our hatcheries and how we can better
maintain what we may do with those
hatcheries and the other funds are used
for alteration of terrain permits
because we hired four individuals
in-house and one of those individuals in
houses being funded through those Des
funds the other three are being funded
directly from arpa funds that came
directly to us
so those are all the arpa funds that
came to us
both the database sorry 1.2 million
dollars came to us just recently for an
upgrade for our database
um overall agency database efficiency
and productivity
thank you any other questions
thank you for your time thank you
because
good morning my name is Garrett
grasskamp I'm the boat access
coordinator for New Hampshire Fish and
Game
and um
right now as Scott said we don't have a
facilities in lands Chief so I'll make a
few comments on that at the end but for
the moment I'll stick to what I know
which is the boat access program
the boat access program
um
started way back in the 1880s 1884 was
the first ramp that was laid out on
behalf for State access on
on
County pond in Newton and in 1945 a law
RSA 230 was passed which initiated the
road to public water program
which ended up building about
96 sites which were very small
some of them half the size of this room
basically as the
the name says it's a road to public
water so built by dot you'd have a
right-of-way 50 feet wide and it would
go right to the edge of the water from
an existing Road
those properties were turned over to the
town to be maintained and managed
but the property itself remained owned
by the the state
uh that bill was repealed in 1992 and
replaced with the current Statewide
Public boat access program
and that's RSA 233-a
that also implemented the public water
access Advisory Board which I work
closely with to determine where we
should have more boat access and that's
been around since really in effect since
again 1990 92 93
um as an aside we
were funded by five dollars for each
boat access sorry boat registration
and I'll go into that a little bit more
later but we do need more access sites
covid got in uh you know what really
highlighted the fact that we don't have
enough access to our Lakes the sites
that we had were
overrun with extra people wanting to use
them
and it was very difficult to get
everybody access in a in a way that they
could be maximize their enjoyment
uh the objective of the program is to
acquire property and construct load
access sites
and then manage them after they are
built we have 135 sites currently of
which 77 are rant cap ramp capable for
uh of handling a trailered boat a normal
size say 20 to 25 foot boat we have an
additional
58 sites that are for car top for your
kayaks and your canoes which are mostly
just gravel access points or a Shore
Bank where we could also do some fishing
program staff
the I'm a program specialist in the
hierarchy of names that the agencies
apply to the people who work for the
state I have a construction Foreman who
works directly for me who does our basic
maintenance on our sites for painting
kiosks building kiosks installing them
and during the summer we hire eight to
nine seasonal employees for a six six
month period and they go around to all
our sites
and pick up trash do the mowing keep
them presentable and safe for the public
that visits our sites
so in comparison to the rest of the
state just to put in perspective we we
manage 135 sites but they're probably
about four to five hundred additional
sites in the state that are managed by
the town or a public utility or some
other
um
entity
those sites are not Public Access sites
the definition of a public access site
is one that's controlled by the state in
other words we either have a lease or a
fioned or an easement on the property
that has Shore front prop uh Shoreline
where we can control access
um
the town sites the the puc sites the
utility sites although they provide
provide Public Access
they are not guaranteed Public Access
because
they can change their mind that entity
can say no I'm not going to have it open
to the public anymore and that happened
a few times when we had covid because
the towns in particular would say wow
our residents can't get on the property
because we have all these other people
that have shown up
um
we just built a new site in the southern
portion southern tip of Alton Bay
it's our first boat ramp on Lake
Winnipesaukee
it has 18
um
ramp parking lots of sorry trailer
parking lots spots on it and that gets
filled up
by probably seven in the morning on a
weekend Into Summer
I went over there I'd live in Gilmanton
I said well I'm up at 6 30. I don't know
why I'm going to drive over and see if
it's full and guess what it was full so
we need more sites we need more the
ability to build more uh boat ramps and
we can't do that without property and so
that costs money
we do
most of our work in-house with that crew
we have two additional construction
um employees if you will in an
engineering Tech and another
construction Foreman
they and we have
um
another person who works in the right on
site at Fish and Game
in Concord
and with those three people in my
construction Foreman
and actually two other Carpenters so we
have about six people that have to
manage and I'm blending here into the
facilities and land information but we
maintain 160 buildings and
um about a hundred Dam sites although we
don't manage the dam sites in particular
but we will you know do the Mowing and
the maintenance there but if a major
repair has to happen then that goes out
to the dam Bureau at DES but six people
to do the work to maintain maintain 160
buildings plus six hatcheries
we basically are stretched lots of times
to get all this work done so that's
something that you should be aware of
um just a lot to be done it's a big a
big effort a fish and game to maintain
uh access and and safe access for the
public
we build our own sites lots of times we
put in a turbidity curtain around the
ramp where we are going to be working to
keep the silt and and uh debris that we
dig up from getting into the channel or
into the lake
we've done a lot of our work in the past
when the water's been shallow to put in
concrete planks which are a little bit
bigger than two of these desks going
down and we put those into the water to
create a pathway for the trailer to back
into
and we've been able to do that in-house
most of the time in the past 30 years or
so
things that we can't do like Paving or
train work we have to hire out
marking the pavement things like that
will hire that that out but anything
that we can build as as a Carpenters or
with earthwork we'll do that ourselves
we have a a full-size excavator that's
25 years old so we're
making that go we have two backhoes we
have two dump trucks and a bobcat and
that's the extent of our equipment that
we're that we can bring to bear on our
projects
foreign
oh funding very important
um Federal funding I have a dedicated
account it's the sport fish restoration
act program that brings in about
550 uh thousand dollars a year
we've been getting that for basically
the entire time for that the program's
been in place since 1992. if you look at
the cost of living
index on that that money is actually
only worth about uh 400 sorry 290
thousand dollars with based on the
Department of Labor inflation factors
0.3.53 it's almost in half from what it
was the other side of our program is uh
funded by or the other funding mechanism
is the state uh boat access excise fee
of five dollars on every boat that's
registered in the state it's motorboats
only in sailboats kayaks and canoes are
not included in that so that five
dollars brings in about 460
000 a year but again the inflation
Factor brings that down to about 290
dollars
so a thousand dollars so we basically
are operating on for about uh five
hundred to six hundred thousand dollars
a year which
that's nineteen ninety two dollars and
you can imagine that with prices on
on the Lakes going up it's very
difficult to ever be able to afford a
property to build a new ramp
um I think I've talked enough and I'd
like to hear if you have any questions
any questions from the committee members
seeing none thank you for your
introduction thank you
we've already forgotten the order so
that we're supposed to go in good
morning my name is Kevin Jordan
um I'm the chief of law enforcement at
New Hampshire Fish and Game uh and I'm
entering my 32nd year uh in law
enforcement
um which just says I don't really have a
life outside of law enforcement I guess
um so we have uh there are two things
I'm very passionate about and you'll
hear it you'll see me a lot over here in
front of the committee I testify a lot
uh there are two things I'm very
passionate about uh one is the mission
of our agency I think it is a it is an
outstanding Mission I think we do a lot
of good for the State of New Hampshire I
can show you and we'll show you that we
bring in a good deal of Revenue I
believe in the sport of hunting and
fishing when it's done correctly and you
will hear me testify in regards to that
I'm also very passionate about the men
and women that I work with that wear
this uniform and you'll hear that come
out on occasion as well so
um and I I don't want to make apologies
for either one of those things I think
they're both very important we have 42
full-time officers that's including me
38 of those are currently field
positions that cover every piece of
ground you see from this town of
Pittsburgh to Massachusetts from Vermont
to Maine and it's not nearly enough
you'll hear that often they're stretched
pretty thin all of them are covering
five to six towns or or more each
running around putting out some of the
fires that we have the city of Concord
has over 50 officers just to give you an
idea we're covering the entire state
with 38.
we joined we being the colonel major and
Captain go out on the weekends I ride an
ATV in the summertime with these guys
because I figure if I ask them to ride
in the dirt and the heat I probably
should be joining them so that we all do
it as a as a team that also keeps you
relevant with the issues that they face
and some of the equipment needs that
they have I understand it if I'm out
there working with them
we enforce all of hunting and fishing
and trapping regulations as you can
imagine uh do conduct all those
investigations uh involving Wildlife we
don't do anything with domestic animals
unless we're assisting a local police
department so we leave them to handle
that but we handled all the wildlife we
handled all the nuisance wildlife animal
calls a majority of them we work in
conjunction with our Wildlife staff they
have a good team of of techs that help
us with bear complaints
um or some of these other bigger large
animal problems when you have a moose
show up in the city of Manchester we
work as a team to to extract the moose
and and get it back out in the wild
we do all the rabies processing the
investigations for rabies calls and we
process the animals and transport them
to Health and Human Services for testing
we enforce all the ATV and ohrv laws so
we're Patrol on snow machines and ATVs
to enforce speed limits we investigate
all the accidents we do Trail
enforcement registration
we participate in all of the outdoor
education classes to include hunter
safety trapping safety trapping classes
oh HIV classes let's go fishing programs
and becoming an outdoors women's program
we do along with Marine Patrol we do the
Inland Fisheries enforcement even though
Marine Patrol is a separate entity we're
enforcing the laws on on boats on our
waterways
we do Coastal marine fisheries
enforcement along our Coastline you're
going to hear a lot more about that in
the next hour we work in partnership
with the national marine fisheries and
the federal we work in both state and
federal waters and we're contracted by
the some of these Federal organizations
because they don't have enough people to
cover this area so that we're all there
this is a huge industry that brings a
good deal of money into the state of New
Hampshire so monitoring that is
critically important
we do all of the search and rescue
Statewide anything from Lost persons to
carryouts for injured hikers so this
includes walkaways or runaways basically
anything that occurs off our highways
become our responsibilities things like
plane crashes major flooding or weather
events and we play a very active role
over at the New Hampshire Emergency
Operations Center as the lead in the
state for search and rescue so we're
probably well known for that because
that's something that we get in the
papers and on the news a lot for some of
these high profile searches it presents
all kinds of challenges for us both for
safety and funding it's never been
funded correctly you'll hear me over
here beating this table as your as the
chairman is nodding his head because
he's seen it many times
our Sportsmen and women pay for that and
I don't think that's fair so we'll
you'll we'll be here asking for your
assistance on occasion to find a better
way to fund that that is something that
is growing
um in great numbers the search and
rescue and it's becoming more and more
dangerous and it's using up a lot of our
resources
we have a lot of specialty teams within
the agency so we had to create an
advanced search and rescue team because
these search and rescue missions were
were putting people in positions where
they weren't trained or equipped for so
we outfitted a small team of 16 officers
and trained them to levels that the
other officers have not been trained to
to respond above tree line at this time
of year when it's 1670 below zero we
have the only dive team within the state
even though Channel 9 will give State
Police Credit for our dive team and is
not theirs it is ours so when you see a
dive team on Channel 9 that is New
Hampshire Fish and Game
incredible team again a small group of
very brave individuals that dive in all
kinds of weather under the ice and in
the summer months we have an underwater
sonar and Camera team which all was
donated a lot of these fund a lot of the
funding for these specialty teams we
went out we didn't have the funding for
it so we went out and raised the money
ourselves or or applied for Grants and
the side scan sonar came to us from
Homeland Security and these guys have
taken it to a level that New Hampshire
has never seen we've solved three
two a double decade cases that were
found people that had been missing for
over 20 years that other agencies had
worked on we were able to locate these
people for families which was pretty
cool using this side scan I've got a
team of guys that are very good with it
and we use that in conjunction with our
drownings and and we're being called on
pretty regularly from State Police and
other agencies for these specialty
skills the colonels have all got
together and we decided that we can
fight over who takes the credit and the
Press when it's over but why don't we
pool our resources together and find
these people and bring them home to
their families if you've got a
helicopter and I've got a side scan
sonar we ought to be able to get it done
we've had great success with that so
um we have an airboat rescue team we
just recently received a 200 000 airboat
free of charge to the state of New
Hampshire that came out of a Homeland
Security Grant an airboat enables us
it's a it's a much safer craft to go on
thin ice we can run it across the
parking lot if we had to uh we have two
of those now we have an old one that I
keep fixing uh that we're going to keep
using and then we have a brand new one
that is state of the art so we're we're
just getting that off off the ground and
using that we have a four member now
canine team that is trained equipped uh
and we maintain solely through donations
there isn't a state dollar in the
canines and they are the best in the
state and I will and I'm not the only
one who's going to tell you that you're
going to see our dogs used in homicides
there you because they're trained in one
uh subject and that is tracking locating
evidence and tracking and just like us
if you if you concentrate on one thing
you become very good at it where a lot
of police dogs are bite dogs they're
tracking dogs they're drug dogs our dogs
are just trained in Scent recovery uh
and they're very good at it so again
they've been involved in in recently the
high profile cases that my dogs found
the evidence in was the Concord
homicides those guns and cartridges were
found by our dogs by Fish and Game dogs
and the homicide up in Northfield the
tragedy of the young man who killed his
mom his stepmom and his children and he
dumped his firearm out on the interstate
some eight miles from the homicide with
the scene in the homicide and our dog
running literally down the middle of the
highway with a with an officer on a
leash found that weapon and and because
of that the individual was arrested and
charged so we're proud of those dogs if
you haven't figured that out
and the state of New Hampshire gets
great service for no cost from that so
we have four of those I'm looking to
expand that we've also ran a pretty
successful little television show for
about 12 Seasons if you haven't seen
northwood's law I would encourage you to
watch it a lot of the reruns are on you
won't see this face this is a radio face
not a television face but there are a
lot of our officers that were on that
and the neat thing about that show it'll
give you some real insight in their
day-to-day activities and some of the
challenges that they face in some of the
issues they deal with so that's still
running what they're not currently
filming now which I'm I'm kind of happy
about is a lot of work but the show was
still being aired so I'd encourage you
to go see that it'll give you a lot of
insight to the agency and all parts of
the agency so
I don't want to take up any more of your
time
thank you thank you any questions from
the committee
representative
thank you chair just to make sure I
understand sure you have roughly 38
officers those 38 are divided into your
dive sonar K9 all of these other things
Specialties yes wow okay thank you yeah
they're a very hard working Bunch yeah
okay thank you thank you you look
familiar to me I'll figure out why you
do what you look I think we've met
probably
are you not using drones as of yet we
are actually that's a good question we
recently got a grant for an 80 000 drone
and it's on order I have a young officer
uh this newer generation is much more
tech savvy than I've ever been and this
young man is pretty good with these
things I made him prove it uh show me
that he could operate one and we could
do that safely and so we are looking to
do that to use it as a more of a search
and rescue tool I'm concerned about
privacy issues using it in
investigations and flying over people's
residents so I don't see it being used
there I I see it more as a resource for
our search missions so we're looking in
that direction
so we are we are barely getting into
that now
yeah
uh representative Willett
thank you Mr chair I just want to say
thank you very much one of the victims
that you found in the Androscoggin river
I knew when I knew his family very well
and I just want to say thank you I
appreciate your hard work and your
dedication to find this man after
decades thank you very much I'll tell
you a quick story just to give you an
idea of the dedication of my staff so
they found that individual this was a
young man who had left a horseshoe
tournament if I remember right some 20
years ago I remember searching for him
and when I was in the field and we never
found him and he literally drove off a
turn into the Androscoggin river and
submerged and there was never a skid
mark we drove up and down the river
looking for skid marks or tracks and we
never saw where he went when he was
located using his side scan he was
actually sitting in the front seat
behind the wheel as he was 20 years ago
when he went in there the sad part was
his mom had passed and she never knew we
found him which which was sad but uh the
leader of my team was contacted right
after that and told about a woman in
1973 who had gone missing in the town of
Gorham driving a Pontiac Le Mans so you
didn't know what a Le Mans was
and he quietly began researching this
case and so when the team was practicing
and using the side scan he would move it
and run these tests in places that he
thought might be where this car would be
he discovers in his research a year
later so he does this for a year without
saying a word I had no knowledge they
were doing this a year later he
discovers this woman had had a daughter
in Gilman Vermont and so he thought
about the Connecticut River so he moved
his training over to the Connecticut
River one night I got a text I got a
call from him kind of a panic call he's
a young his name is Joe Canfield he's a
good he's a good officer and he called
me he says Colonel I'm going to send you
because I'm a car guy I have hot rods I
that was my former life he said I'm
going to send you a picture of a car I
think it's a Pontiac Le Mans can you
tell me if it's a Pontiac LeMans and he
sent me a text picture of a side scan
sonar of a Pontiac LeMans sitting upside
down in the Connecticut River I said
that's Pontiac LeMans Joe he said I
can't read the plate but I think it's
her this was a woman Mrs Lehman who had
gone Miss in 1973 I said we're going to
keep this between us for now and
tomorrow we'll send the dive team up
there and we'll grab that plate and if
in fact that's our plate we'll determine
if she's in that car and then we'll let
the press and and go get the family
because it was important for me to I
wanted to find the family first so we
went back over there and sure enough it
was Mrs Lehman and she was in the car so
we went down the road to find this poor
woman the daughter and her aunt was
there 80 year old woman and we walked in
and I had two stars from the Northwest
law program that are on my side scan she
thought we were bringing the Stars to
the show to meet her aren't because she
loved the show so we let that go for a
few minutes and then we sat them down
and I said I think I found you we found
your mother up the road she'd been there
that whole time and this poor woman had
flown to Nevada she'd gone to Colorado
you know following leads and her mom was
up the road less than a mile for 20
years so there was some real
satisfaction to finding these people and
bringing resolve to these cases so I was
was very proud of Joe and his team for
doing that
sorry thank you representative pair
I've also also watched a few episodes of
Northwoods is there any income to the
department from that the good questions
kind of so we we never could take we
didn't want to ever take money because
we felt that people would say oh you're
only doing this to generate money and
you're paying these stars and so what we
did we asked the company to make
donations to our non-profit partner
which is a wildlife Heritage Foundation
for every episode that was on and I kind
of we kind of negotiated that and I
didn't know anywhere near as much about
television as I do today because I would
have negotiated uh much more
aggressively I would have figured in
something for reruns because we didn't
and so they ended up every time an
episode was aired they sent a two
thousand dollar check to the Heritage
Foundation and the company owner was so
happy about the success of the program
he would send ten thousand dollar checks
and and I would call him and say you
sent way too much money and he'd say no
I want that to go to the Heritage which
kind of gave me an idea how much money
they were making
so we made a mistake there and if we
ever renegotiate that contract it's
going to be approached in a different
way the other thing that I insisted on
the contract was full edit rights so
what you see is we have control over and
I was very glad we did that because in
the example of the truck they wanted to
show that skeleton coming up in the
truck because it makes for great
television you know we're concerned
about families in New Hampshire and I
didn't want kids watching this show at
seven o'clock at night to see that and I
said and I was convinced I said this
show will succeed without that and it
did so we would we would keep those at
it right so they wouldn't have us on so
thank you any other questions from the
committee
representative
I have a really simple one uh the
canines that you have what breed are
they they are Labradors so uh we have
every color Labrador
um and those are donated through a board
member on the wildlife Heritage
Foundation and they are they all come
from Rise and Shine kennels hunting dogs
they are incredible dogs and they are
part of the family I can assure you
thank you yes I also want to introduce
someone else I hope I'm not stepping out
of line director but I want to introduce
seated right behind me is Marty Mobley
who was our legislative coordinator for
the state for the department so she is
someone else that you will see pretty
regularly over here
um some of you may know her if you've
been in the house for any length of time
she was an assistant to rep Senator
Bradley here for many years and we stole
her not from Senator Bradley but we
stole her from the insurance business
and she works for us now so she will be
here a lot with us and three or four of
the Chiefs that you see behind me thank
you very much thank you
uh any other questions no okay we'll
move on
do I hit the it's working I can hear it
hi so my name is Diane Timmins I'm the
Inland Fisheries division Chief I am
rooted in field biology I've been
working with the department for 27 years
now and um just recently I like to say
recently Kathy keeps telling me I can't
say I'm the new kid anymore but I keep
using that excuse it helps on the things
that I'm still learning so I started as
the Fisheries division Chief in July of
21 so I guess technically I have been
here for a little while so
um but first I'd like to just talk about
who the Inland Fisheries division is and
then also what we do so there are 38 of
us that does include hatcheries as
director Mason had mentioned and the
Hatchery people are there's 27 people in
our hatcheries there's six full active
hatcheries on throughout the state and
27 people reside there and then 11
people were work in the Inland Fisheries
division so in the I say Inland
Fisheries we're all Inland Fisheries but
the biological staff so there's Regional
Offices spread throughout the state
there's usually two Inland Fisheries
division folks there at each office and
then so up North Region one middle part
of the state region two Marine Division
Region 3 and headquarters as well as
region four and then within headquarters
we have a few staff as well so it seems
like there's a big group of us but we're
really not all together ever so
um but then we also have one vacant
position that's a hatchery supervisor so
that person would oversee all six
facilities and all the projects
especially those related to arpa and so
if anybody knows anybody that's slightly
chaotic lots of energy and maybe
slightly
um
I don't know how to say it properly but
maybe up here a little loose wants to
come to our Hatchery position come on
board because it is chaos but we really
need a person so super it's exciting we
have a lot of really good projects and
um we're really excited about the
modernization project and the
feasibility
um representative Harvey had asked about
the feasibility that one is actually
working to identify what we can do and
identify what our best step would be
what our next step should be and then
the 55 million modernization project
will be working toward that and
activating that action so
um and there's five Pro our funding
comes from our dedicated license sales
as well as the habitat fee so our
Fisheries license and habitat fee as
well as the federal programs you know
Dingle Johnson 75 25 percent
um us and then private donations as well
as some minor other things
so our staff Works in really five
designated programs we have the cold
water program that includes wild trout
quality pond fishing
stocking all of that type of stuff is
really involved in that it's a really
really quick summary for a very big
umbrella so all of our Brookshire work
that's done throughout the state all of
that is included in that cold water
program so there's a lot of staff that
are actively involved in a multitude of
federal organizations Federal
collaborations and Partnerships and all
of that is working toward cold water
stuff so our Hatchery six of them we
stock over a million fish in the state
of New Hampshire and that's between 700
lakes and 900 streams so that's mostly
what we stock now back in the olden days
we had stocked everything under the sun
you name it Pacific salmon in the
Atlantic portion of the world seems a
little crazy but we did it and now we're
predominantly focused on landlocked
salmon Rainbow Trout Brook Trout and
brown trout
we have the Fisheries habitat
restoration and land conservation
program so that's looking at Dam
removals looking at stream Crossing
restoration projects looking at
um
land protection all of that is involved
in that program we also have the large
lakes program so that's mostly what you
see in Winnipesaukee Squam the
Connecticut Lake Sunapee all those big
lake areas that do landlocked salmon and
smelt work forage studies that we do in
the summer those are done at night boat
with lots of electricity if anybody's
ever seen folks like why are these
people out here at you know 11 P.M to
midnight or sometimes one o'clock two
o'clock in the morning that's for our
forage study base and those the smaller
fish the smelt juveniles and yellow
perch and white perch tend to come up to
the surface a little bit so we can
actually
collect them and do samples to be able
to determine where what our capacity is
for salmon for the following year
so um then we also have our Fish
Conservation program so that's mostly
looking at our threatened and endangered
species as well as our migratory species
and species of greatest concern so that
program is actively involved it also
deals with the wildlife action plan
which is a huge part of our strategic
operation
the warm water program is Largemouth
smallmouth bass we call those black bass
but and Sunfish work as well as warm
water habitat work and then also bass
tournaments that occur throughout the
state a lot of those are on our bigger
Lakes but all of that needs to be
managed and gets permitted and all of
that happens in the Inland Fisheries
division
so um more on what we do so we manage in
a nutshell we manage monitor can and
conserve fish species in their habitats
and basically we're looking at not only
the species but also what opportunities
we can provide to our Anglers so it's
not just the fish part of it so to speak
it's all of that plus the public
Outreach and education so looking to
make sure that everybody understands and
we're all on the same page on the
conservation as well as the use we want
to make sure that people are able to
have a good time out there so
collaborate a lot with Garrett on access
and yes Big Dreams with access we never
turn it down
um so the other thing we do the
monitoring of threatened and endangered
species we have tons of threatened and
endangered fish species in the state of
New Hampshire some of the big ones are
American Brook Lamprey Bridal Shiner
Whitefish and other migratory fish such
as Shad eels and some Atlantic salmon
still
then we conduct and coordinate
scientific research we collaborate with
a multitude of non-governmental
organizations as well as Plymouth State
University as well not so much with UNH
because they don't have a Fisheries
program but they do have some Fisheries
classes and now that I'm in this
position that partnership I hope will
grow because that's something I'd like
to do but we also do work with other
out-of-state entities as well as far
down south as Virginia and Pennsylvania
um and then we also provide technical
assistance on a variety of grant
opportunities with municipalities as
well as those non-governmental
organizations so working with trout
unlimited working with various towns as
I mentioned for stream Crossing projects
Dam removals land protection anything
like that that would benefit our fish
species and their habitat so with that
I'll take any questions
any questions from the committee yes Mr
Vice chair
thank you Mr chair sorry good morning
where are you
uh just a quick question on I know last
year there was an issue trying to get
rainbow trout in the stocking and you
know what I'm talking about how is that
looking for this year going forward it
looks great so we um collected extra
species to be safe so we actually have a
little bit of an overage right now
um but still there's still some there's
always natural mortality in the
hatcheries that just occurs
um so we have a buffer for that and but
everything is looking awesome I think
that we we are doing the numbers right
now and everything looks great
excellent thank you I mean I found
Plenty of Fish out there but I just
can't imagine if there was more of what
it would be like it was still really
good fishing yeah we weren't actually
short by I was just looking at this
there were
um over 50 Waters that didn't get fished
last year that normally get rainbow
trout because of our shortage so
any other questions
representative
thank you Mr chair if I understand
correctly when a pond is stocked uh
there's no process to let fishermen know
that it that it's stocked is that
somebody a buddy of mine who's an avid
fisherman told me that is that an
accurate assessment no and I'm glad you
asked that question so thank you
um so we started last year an online
active map that actually shows all of
the stocking in New Hampshire it happens
two days after the stocking event has
occurred just so we have time to qaqc
make sure somebody didn't add an extra
zero and then the following Year
everybody would be looking forward to
that extra zero and it would not occur
so it just gives us a couple just to
make sure everything's right but the
active program is is on our website and
you can click on that it's under stock
going to fisheries and under stocking
and you click on the active map and
there's a map that shows you what was
stocked and so you can go to it via the
where you are locate related to C and
then there's also a table below that
gives you the summary awesome thank you
you're welcome
yep
it's the same six 12 year old boys
spoke about the entire state but
sorry Kevin is his Fame that's mine
okay any other questions
okay on a time management uh question
here we've got uh two three minutes here
before we have to actually uh open up
the hearing on our bill how many more
speakers do we have and
okay
um
why don't we go ahead and continue with
the next speaker
um
now and then uh at 11 I'm going to uh
have to open up the bill and then recess
it briefly while you finish
chairman and thanks for providing the
time today
um to come in and talk about the
different divisions
as the Director mentioned Dan Bergeron
who is our Wildlife division Chief is in
a senate hearing this morning so
um I'm gonna fill in for him um I'm the
game program supervisor for the Wildlife
Division and that's a very new position
for me I've been in that position for
about two months now I served in the
Department's bear biologists for the
past 21 years and I've been with the
agency about 28. but to talk a little
bit about the wildlife Division and and
who we are and what we do we have 32
full-time staff in the wildlife Division
and On Any Given summer depending on
funding we might have up to about 10
seasonals and most of these people that
fill these positions have advanced
degrees in either wildlife management or
conservation biology it's it's a very
competitive field you know a lot of
people wanna
you know work for a while uh natural
resource the management agency so the
work we do kind of falls into five broad
categories and these include game
management uh non-game and endangered
species management land conservation and
habitat management data collection entry
and Analysis you know data is always
necessary to make good good
science-based management decisions as
well as the mitigation of wildlife human
conflicts and animal damage which is an
increasing thing that that we're dealing
with it with his managers our funding is
is primarily through the sale of hunting
licenses and dedicated species-specific
permits but also as others have
mentioned uh the the Federal Federal
grant monies in addition to that there
are some other funding sources for some
of the wildlife division programs
specifically as it relates to non-game
and that that includes the revenue from
the sale of the Moose license plate as
well as private donations by individuals
to the non-game program which is matched
up to a hundred thousand dollars through
state general fund money so you know
very important funding sources for for
those non-game programs so what we do
well we we manage the various game
species in the state this includes dear
moose bear turkey small game fur bearers
as well as waterfalls so we manage those
species keep those populations
at socially acceptable levels and
provide that recreational opportunity to
folks we can serve and monitor uh
non-game and threatened species
including a various species of turtles
species such as cottontail rabbits bald
eagles
peregrine falcons Carnival butterflies
and in in addition to the ones I've
mentioned there's a lot of additional
species on the list that really require
very specific conservation need
we conduct and coordinate scientific
research to inform decision making and
New Hampshire has been one of the
leading States in New England with some
pretty important research activities
over the past several years many of
these related to to Moose and kind of
the plight that moose are facing in our
in our current ecosystem
we can serve and manage habitat for
wildlife on approximately sixty Thousand
Acres owned by the Hampshire fishing
game and an additional Twenty Thousand
Acres that we've been able to conserve
through easement
and we provide technical assistance to
municipalities industrial Forest land
owners as well as smaller private
landowners people who are interested in
conserving Wildlife on their on their
properties the notion of of these Timber
companies is really a thing of the old
days most of these large Forest lands in
the northern part of the state are now
owned by investment companies but
nonetheless they're they're big tracks
of land open to public access open to
recreational hunting and fishing and
trapping and we have an ability to work
closely with them to to improve these
these large Forest blocks for for
increased wildlife habitat and Wildlife
production
and we also spend a lot of you know as
our as our human populations grow and as
our our species population grows it's
putting humans in in Critters in Greater
um Conflict at a higher rate you know
we're all trying to share space so the
wildlife division invests a lot of time
and resources into mitigating conflicts
between wildlife and um in the public
and kind of our approach is to try to
minimize these conflicts to education we
provide technical assistance we also
have a very uh popular
program where we loan out abatement
materials things such as electric
fencing those type of things and our
ultimate goal here is we're trying to
teach people how to coexist with with
our critters here in the state and
increase tolerance and in one reason
we've been able to successfully have the
program that we have in New Hampshire is
we have a unique partnership with the
federal agency USDA wildlife services
and that is a relationship that's unique
to New Hampshire so we've been very
fortunate that we've been able to invest
a lot of resources into that into that
program
I'm going to be brief because I want to
leave any time for anybody else but if
there's any questions I'm happy to
to take some I think we'll hold the
questions and we'll get back to the
questions after we deal with the the
bill that we've got coming up because
it's uh after 11 now and we're supposed
to start around 11. okay but thank you
appreciate it thank you for your
testimony
okay
absolutely
thank you so much for your patience and
and um for sticking around those who can
stick around to answer questions still
and with that I'm going to open the
hearing on uh 442 FN
chair recognizes uh the prime sponsor of
the bill
Greg Hill
foreign
to have the bill introduced I want to
explain uh across procedure technicality
that I found out about this morning in
the chairs meeting we have two
amendments uh that I've been notified
about coming on this bill but they are
extensive enough they're not just minor
Corrections that they are going to
require their own noticed public hearing
so uh what we will get to talk about or
listen to today is is anybody who wants
to testify on the underlying bill but
not so much the Amendments we will get
an introduction to what those amendments
are but the hearings for those will be
noticed uh separately at a later date
and I'm going to intend to do an exact
session following those amendments
public hearing
people
Mr chair I'm not sure I fully understood
that
do you want me to just testify on the
bill as we have you may also speak about
the Amendments but we have to notify
those for another public hearing right
on the amendment they will have a more
thorough public hearing individually
on another day understood but they can
be talked about today and and uh
discussed
great
we ready
go for it uh good morning everyone
um my name is uh representative Greg
Hill I uh I represent the town of
Northfield
um Merrimack too
um I'm here before you today to discuss
House Bill
which as you can hear is uh somewhat at
a period of flux
um we uh I should give you a little of
the history of how this occurred
we were contacted
I think a half hour before the deadline
of filing legislation and uh by someone
purported to be
a spokesperson or at least a member of
the lobstering community and asked if we
would file legislation for them
um
what you see in front of you on the
first part is that is what that was
requested it was a request to submit
legislation to
[Music]
um
ask that no state funds be used to
enforce federal regulations
in a nutshell or in in totality
um
since then and since the bill came out
and was approved we have some new
knowledge and that's in the form of this
commentary that I passed out to you just
a second ago
and that says on the very first page
Maine's delegation Congressional
Delegation amended the federal spending
Bill to delay the new regulations until
2028 and called for more research on
whale entanglements and ropeless fishing
gear
um
Maine's delegation was able to do what
no one else was able to do apparently
and delay this for uh about six years
um should have been a collective sigh of
relief and and um and somewhat guarded
um exaltation by uh by the lobstering
community I believe
um
where that goes I don't know obviously
and I don't think anyone does but we
were attempting to to help
the lobstering community with what
seemed to be onerous and and um
overreactive regulations
having that that change in the law or
that
modification in the law meant that that
single line in this bill
was rendered we don't we don't need it
so that's one part of the amendment
that's coming is to eliminate that line
second part of the bill
um is is the return of the
discussion and on allowing our New
Hampshire residents access to the
natural resource Lobsters by utilizing
scuba and and
10 10 digits at least for the short term
10 digits to uh to access lobsters our
natural resources yeah you got it
um but uh but what we um are hoping to
put forth is is an amendment to um to
again try to work with the the
lobstering community and this is the the
other parts of the amendment which I
think is on the table over to our side
yes
um
and that is to um
to somewhat work on
um one of the key phrases that's used
constantly in our natural resources
which is sustainability
um there is a
unknown to to many
um perhaps even on this committee is uh
our our impediments to our natural
resource which are contained in bycatch
which is what the other article was
talking about
and also ghost traps
um I'll give you a quick primer on ghost
traps
there's estimates of as high as 10
percent of the lobster and gear that
commercial lobsters use that that get
lost every year either by boat traffic
or by storms or whatever
they are no longer accessible from the
surface
and uh and we passed a bill uh two years
ago that I've lost the number for 147
Senate Bill 147 that charged all of
these guys an extra fee in order to do
cleanup Coastal cleanup
um it started last January and so
they've just collected one year worth of
fees
interestingly the bill doesn't include
cleanup underwater it only includes the
cleanup on on shore
well
any diver can tell you that is been out
anywhere beyond their knees that there
are literally thousands of traps that
remain in our Coastal Waters that that
catch continued to catch even though
they're underwater there's been a couple
of attempts to redesign traps so that
they have biodegradable discs
some of those work some of the time some
of them take a longer time to to
dissolve in order to allow the the
lobsters that are inside well I should
say all creatures that are inside
because there's sometimes fish sometimes
crabs sometimes Lobster inside those
traps to escape
however storms sometimes tip them on the
sides so those those biodegradable discs
don't work sometimes it's just a tangle
you can't believe on the floor from
oceans and The Surge
so there are mountains literally
mountains of of traps that continue to
catch Lobster and and it's a continuous
process so a lobster goes in gets gets
caught in there dies that becomes bait
for the next lobsters to come in and die
and they are saying uh from the from
every reading that I've keep coming up
with the 10 number the 10 is what the
number of lobsters traps that are lost
in a year so we know pretty much what
that number would be
um and and those are continuing by and
large to uh to fish some get damaged
beyond recognition but some still exist
there are a couple of different
organizations one is called drag in
Portsmouth the other is oceans-wide and
I and you received a a video over the
weekend of Ocean's wide operation
because they had a really nice short
explanation of how they operate their
goal is to get these ghost traps
out of our fishing Waters
and and thereby you should you should be
aware or you should have made the
connection that that ghost traps catch
indiscriminately so they could be
catching pregnant females with you know
as many as 10 000 eggs on them so you
know all of that goes to the
sustainability is is to my way of
thinking it would be in all of our best
interests
divers lobstermen
um
anyone that cares about our community to
get rid of those ghost traps as
efficiently and and as quickly as we can
I maintain the most efficient manner to
do that is uh with a partnership with
with our scuba diving community
and to that end you'll you'll hear from
people that own dive shops that would be
willing to help with the uh with the
training and and
Arrangements in that line I'll let them
speak to that but that's part of the
additional amendment that we're coming
in with to try to figure out a way that
we can actually work together increase
sustainability
increase
all of the operation at the same time we
allow scuba divers to have some access
on a on a non-commercial recreational
basis right now we do have a
non-commercial license which allows
um New Hampshire residents to have five
pots
I think it is maybe it's tent I keep
going back on that Massachusetts I think
is 10 I'm not sure if we're five but the
point is you have to have a boat you
have to live somewhere near the coast
you have to have a very forgiving spouse
to be able to let you go and visit your
traps every uh every couple of days it
is it's an extensive process where
someone that is a diver could be living
in koas county and come down for a day
with it with their license we have also
set up designated areas so to help with
the complaints or the concerns that we
had from fish and game that felt that
they were unable to enforce it
um we we are suggesting designated areas
that would be diving only so they could
be visible from the shore they could
witness the divers coming out of the
water with with and count to five you
know or three I forget what the number
is that moves around too it's a short
season but our goal is to try to
um
solicit or or enable our New Hampshire
residents access to this natural
resource I could go on as you can
imagine but I'm happy to leave it here
and let the professionals that are
coming behind me answer
some of the questions but I'm happy to
take whatever questions anyone has now
thank you representative does anybody
have any questions
yes you've been recognized
um representative Cobalt just a
procedural question with respect to the
Amendments I know that the Amendments
will
get a hearing at another time but I see
that
um
Amendment 195.
replaces all text after the enacting
clause
Amendment 196 replaces section one
so if we adopt 195 and then 196 I think
we are
achieving an unintended consequence if
we go in the opposite order
I I suspect because if we if we adopt
195 then section one which is replaced
with 196 is is gone at that point if I'm
reading this correctly if we do it in
the opposite order
um
and adopt 196 first then 195 obliterates
196. so uh just I I may be reading that
wrong but uh if if if I'm correct then
we probably need either a single clean
Amendment or to correct some of that
language so that we're not stepping on
one with the other
uh thank you for your question
representative I I believe you're you're
absolutely correct um but we will this
will be handled I think I I I don't know
the procedure that's been talked about
with internally
um so I'm happy to leave it in the hands
of your of your very capable leadership
team
Madam clerk I recognize you
thank you so whilst representative
kofault is correct about that effect in
adopting multiple amendments on the
floor my understanding of process is
that when committees adopt multiple
amendments there cannot be more than one
committee Amendment OLS has to merge all
said amendments together and then create
the committee's intended Amendment so
that is not a risk for committee
amendments being adopted but it is
indeed a risk for floor amendments being
adopted
thank you representative
any other questions yes representative
Brown
uh thank you chair for taking my
question on line three and four uh of
the original
uh proposal
a couple uh I'll do this one question at
a time tier if I can
um State resources means fish and game
and or
possibly who else State the the word
State there means Fish and Game
resources
um
it really uh thank you for your question
um that's the part that's going to be
removed so it's it's not uh
it's not an issue that it won't be part
of the original bill it won't be part of
the bill when we get to a vote here on
the committee okay follow-up
follow-up thank you so you you said that
that line will come out
because of what the main congressive
delegation managed to accomplish right
but as I read them they aren't the same
thing
lobstering regulations is what you have
in line three and four and the main
Congressional delegations work is on
whale entanglements on ropless fishing
gear so I don't can can you or someone
following you explain how the main
Congressional work is eliminating this
line for lobstering regulations
um I can try but I'm certain that
there's somebody that can do it better
um
thank you okay
any other questions yes representative
Smith thank you Mr chairman
um do you have any experience if this
proposal or idea is successful in the
adjoining States
Maine and Massachusetts uh thank you for
your question
um by this proposal you mean
the the diver
correct okay
um I wasn't sure whether you were
talking about ghost trap cleanup or
anything like that
um as far as uh his current law
um
scuba diving for lobsters is legal in
all states on the East Coast except for
New Hampshire and Maine
um so that's where the experience exists
I actually for point of information I
actually do still control and have a a
Massachusetts license for scuba diving
by hand
any other questions
seeing none thank you representative
thank you Mr chairman always a pleasure
to be in Fish and Game
and the chair is going to call Weldon
Bosworth
I'm going to try to hold people to their
time that they've asked so I'll give you
a five minute reminder if you uh hit
five minutes
put half on each end and we'll pass them
down thank you
Mr chairman members of the committee my
name is Weldon Bosworth I'm a resident
of Guilford
and I was asked by the proponents of
this bill
to testify as to some of his issues that
have been raised by it
now I was asked because of my training
experience I actually am a marine
biologist I've got over 45 years
experience evaluating impacts to Marine
creatures and I have a PhD as well
though I'm retired now
so I have a pretty lengthy testimony
there and I'm not going to try to go
through it but there are a couple of
issues there I'm going to address and
just to emphasize
I actually passed out a little primer
there for questions to ask
which you're free to ask me or uh you
know witnesses that are speakers that
are going to testify in advance
first of all I'm a citizen of New
Hampshire and I should have
the opportunity as a diver to get
Harvest hunt for lobsters I can do it
for scallops by diving I can Spear Fish
by diving I can do it for crabs
as long as I stay within the limits and
the size that's perfectly legal and yet
we have this like barrier here to for me
to go and get some Lobsters by diving I
used to do that when I was growing up in
Massachusetts and I know a lot about it
I know a lot about the near shore
benthic environment of New Hampshire I
did I was a manager of all the Baseline
studies for Seabrook station
I did a lot of them down in the piscata
corps for Schiller station and Newington
so I've got uh let's say hundreds of
hours there underwater observing the
Marine habitat so I think it's really uh
prejudicial that I am not allowed as a
citizen of New Hampshire New Hampshire
who pays taxes to go after another
public trust resource that of lobsters
so what is the impact of uh taking
Lobsters by uh by diving it's far less
than it is by taking them with traps
basically it's a very passive activity
you try to find the things first of all
which is difficult you try to lure them
on of where wherever they're hidden
under either seaweed or the rocks and
either using deception or what they call
a tickle stick you get them out where
you can grab them very little impact
with Trap Fishing you basically have
traps on the bottom which are dragged
when they're pulled up some people use
trawls of many traps when you hook them
up and the boat's moving either by wind
or by Tides you can see it drags across
the bottom
the lobster is caught in the Trap that
are not keepers are thrown overboard as
they float to the bottom they're
vulnerable to any predator until they
find a new home with diving if it's not
the one you want not the one you're
going to take you basically leave it
alone or if you take it out to measure
it you put it back where it came from
so I think the impact is very very low
let's talk about it in terms of the
relative impact to the Lobster in terms
of pounds taken New Hampshire Landings
over the last five or six years have
range from five to six million pounds of
lobsters
that's a lot of lobsters the
recreational license allows you to take
a certain amount and the latest data I
found the landings for recreational
Lobster fishermen are about 0.5 percent
I have these numbers in my testimony of
that five to six million which makes it
somewhere on 25 to 30 000 pounds
on the other hand my calculations for
what we expected by divers in the time
that's been allotted by this bill and
the anticipated limits and the fact that
a lot of people don't want to uh you
know die three or four times a week I'd
say is around two to four thousand uh
pounds of lobsters per year
so it's
what we used to say in the Consulting
industry it's de minimis impact
last uh I just want to briefly discuss
the enforcement ask aspect of it because
in previous hearings this has come up as
something that's really different from
what conservation officers like Colonel
Jordan have to do
I see this is no different than their
responsibilities with a number of
different activities that they have to
basically enforce and I have a list of
them in there but I know you dig clams
over in the Hampton seaberg Flats
there's nobody there they're watching
them from the shore with a spotting
scope or something or from a boat you
got head boats out there fishing three
miles offshore they may check them out
when they come back you got people out
there hunting seabook sea Ducks Before
Dawn or just at dawn off the coast
they get them when they get back if they
can see them when they get back now in
the bill that's set up here they
anticipate a zone for taking lobsters
which is no more than 100 meters or
yards offshore
and near points of access
to the ocean so you can a parking lot or
something like that the divers are going
to have numbers on their tanks or their
flags and when they come in there they
can be asked to show what they got so I
don't see enforcement as any more of a
insurmountable task as all the other
hunting and fishing activities that the
conservation office have to enforce and
I'll stop there that must be five
minutes at least
okay and almost but thank you are there
any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
sure thing
the chair is going to call Eric Anderson
who's asked for three minutes
thank you Mr chair I've got some copies
I didn't make enough if you give them to
the clerk we'll take care of copies
thank you
uh good morning Mr chair and committee
um thank you very much for this
opportunity
um I'm here expressing my name is Eric
Anderson I'm from Portsmouth New
Hampshire
um
I've had over 50 years of experience in
the water in the variety of marine
fisheries at the State of New Hampshire
offers I'm here expressing my thoughts
and opinions on House Bill 442
enacting as president of the New
Hampshire commercial Fisherman's
Association that is in opposition of
this bill
I have been in front of this committee
at least five previous times
as this bill has yet to go into the full
support of the legislature
the New Hampshire Fish and Game
Commission the New Hampshire Fish and
Game department in the New Hampshire
Marine advisory committee opposes such a
legislation I hope you respect their
expertise opinion and conclusion not to
support the bill
you will hear or have heard rational and
logical testimonies don't allow this
bill to move forward and I'll list some
of the reasons for you to consider it
for New Hampshire for our state of New
Hampshire citizen is not being denied
with access to this resource and
depending on one's level of commitment
they can obtain a license to Harvard Law
Officers by means of trapping
the state of New Hampshire has over a
hundred year history of managing and
harvesting this resource by means of
trapping this strategy has proven well
in sustaining the resource
this is not a wild fishery as one might
suspect it to be
lobstering is a a form of aquaculture
um the commercial sector spends millions
of dollars a year and millions of pounds
of bait to Foster this resource and
um
there's been plenty of studies to
conclude that if you take traps away
from the if you take traps out of the
water the lobsters disappear
they've done a variety of studies on the
effects of trapping and and
the success of the resource
uh you will hear from
or have you will hear from the top
official for the New Hampshire fishing
game enforcement that allowing The
Taking of officers by divers is not
enforceable
and creates logistic and enforcement
nice nightmares why is the responsible
committee for natural resources would
you disregard that advice
we respect the management enforcement
actions of New Hampshire fishing game
and hope you might do the same
allowing two different group user groups
to harvest the same resource in the same
area and proximity create safety
concerns of enormous consequences a
diver in the same proximity of a trap
fisherman is simply not a good set of
circumstances and you as a committee
should promote safety in your
consideration
you might hear of derelict traps or the
concern of their work traps and the
concerned mortality of the lobsters that
that might be in these traps in fact the
current lobster trap is tremendously
inefficient
in the way it catches lobsters
there are multiple accounts there are
multiple conservation components built
into the trap to allow for escape
in the course of the seven years
it takes a lobster to mature and grow to
a legal length it has been in that trap
it has been in traps thousands of times
and it knows how to maneuver in and out
of that trap so the mortality issue I
don't think is a legitimate reason for
any concern to this discussion
you lay here today for management
concerns and disruption of habitat and
the means of harvesting officers by
diving is not the best practice I hope
you respect that that opinion as there
is a hopeful testimony will incur
um I preference these comments to note
that throughout the range of harvesting
lobsters in the Gulf of Maine currently
New Hampshire Maine and Canada
do not allow diving falopsis to the
south of us the Commonwealth of
Massachusetts does and from indications
of from their law enforcement regime it
regrets that allowance
um being born and brought up in New
Hampshire I might not agree with the
policies of my neighbors to the south in
closing you've heard a well-haired
testimony the challenges and questions
or reasons to oppose House Bill 442 to
move forward I hope you take the
responsible action to it all this
legislation thank you very much
thank you are there any questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony yep
the chair is going to call uh Louis
figuera or Louis figuero
ask for 10 minutes
so it is still okay good he left it on
all right thank you for your time my
name is Louis Figueroa I'm a resident of
Merrimack and I'm in support of House
Bill 442 with the
We're not gonna do the post amendments
all right
um by introduction I'm a Dive Master and
act as a dive guide for one of the local
dive shops in Merrimack New Hampshire
called aquatic Specialties as a dive
professional what I do is I guide divers
and uh on Charter Dives and Dives short
Dives in the area I've been scuba diving
uh you know for over 40 years having
logged probably most of the Dives in the
waters of New Hampshire
um but like Greg I'm also a resident I
have uh property on Cape Cod so I I have
a mass Lobster license so I'm familiar
with
um you know what it's like to dive
recreationally for lobsters off the
water of Cape Cod and Cape Ann
um
one of the things that uh a strong feel
that lobsters are a natural resource
just that it should be
um uh accessible to to you know everyone
as opposed to a limited few
um just like we can take scallops and so
on I um but also
you know I understand that yes we can
take lobsters with a five pot
non-commercial license but as Craig
pointed out you have to have a boat you
have to uh you have to bait the the the
the fish and you have to bait the pots
and and and it's it's just not practical
for someone me living in Merrimack
driving to this ecos to do that
um the one thing that I really wanted to
point out is I completely understand
that this is a valuable resource for the
state and not just here but in in Maine
and and all the surrounding states
um what we're proposing is I think it's
a compromise because we're limiting the
season as opposed to year round like in
Massachusetts and and South
we're limiting the catch
um you know set by the the fishing game
the we're also uh restricting the number
of permits
and um and then we're even looking at uh
We've proposed even restricting it to
limiting it to certain zones
um uh where we can where you can fish
um the other thing that was also added
was that we're we're going to collect
data on The Landings
um in Massachusetts when you renew your
permit you put in how many you catch and
where and so on so they have that data
um we're going to go a step further and
and act and what we propose is when
you're out of the water within a certain
you know six hour period we can just
like as if I'm a Hunter and I hunt for
something I shoot something I I report
what I what I shot
um so we would have that that data
reported um so that we at least at the
end of the season we'll or we'll we'll
have an A an idea of the percentage of
Landings are uh catch bought caught by
recreational scuba divers
um so that you know the other thing is
that uh I I did consult with some of the
other experts in in the area like for
example the uh Massachusetts Department
of Marine Resources
um you know they're they're letting us
know that it's less than five percent of
all the landings that uh are caught in
you know through commercial and
non-commercial pots um and diverses are
are caught in the state of Massachusetts
as far as enforcement I also consulted
with uh some of the environmental police
um who all admitted that this is not an
issue that they spend a lot of
inordinate amount of time policing um
you know the
they they're mostly focused on uh the
random checks that they're doing
checking people checking fish and
measuring the the size of the fish and
lobsters but they're not there's that
perception that uh conservation officers
or environmental police have to be in
the water in In Scuba Diving catching
um uh you know culprits it it's just far
from the truth so it's not a big
Enforcement issue in the state and
um obviously I had asked if they could
be willing to testify to that but they
said they can't because they have to
appear objective on both the DMR and the
environmental police
but one of the things I wanted to point
out what if you look at what we're
proposing of a hundred permits per year
for a limited season
um
during that season if if in a two-month
period I think a diver would be lucky if
they're getting maybe five to ten
lobsters
um through recreational scuba diving in
that time
um I would doubt that there would
probably be more than 50 divers that
would actually seek those permits so if
you do the math we're only talking
you know 250 to 500 lobsters that would
be caught through uh recreational scuba
diving so
um I don't think it's a big number but
the uh
the last thing I wanted to do is that
that talk about is that
I wanted to help everyone understand
that what we're what we're doing is
actually better than if I were to get a
boat and get a five pot non-commercial
license
the way that I get lobsters today it's
it's a lot less as as well then
testified passive because I'm not
dragging my pots along the bottom and
then when I bring up my lobsters I'm
um I'm checking them I'm checking to see
if they're egg bearing I'm checking them
for size and then I'm dropping them back
in and during that time they're exposed
to you know uh predators and and striped
bass whereas when you're diving you're
actually at the source you're looking
you're you're you're you're
um you see one and you look at it you
you can quickly tell if it's legal or
not you have to size it before you you
can't bring it up to the surface and
then size it you have to have it sized
right there and you put it right back
where where it is so it's not
susceptible to Predators uh during that
period
um so I just want to kind of reinforce
that this is a little bit more
sustainable but the other thing is that
we're not
you're gonna
um there's that night that
perception that divers are disrupting
the bottom and and especially during the
period when lobsters are more
susceptible to Predators when they've
just molted or
um when they're very young we're not
dragging lifting up rocks or or
um to to find them it's a very difficult
challenging
to find one and when you do find one you
it it's not that easy to you don't pull
them out by the claws you have to really
it's not a sustainable method to grab
them by the closet there's practices
that um someone else will talk about on
on how to sustainably harvest lobsters
in a way that's safe for the environment
um through education so those are the
only things I wanted to bring up but
just lastly it's just uh that this also
going to help I think the local dive
shop communities the some of the dive
shops on the Seacoast uh like the shop
that I represent to to draw more uh
people into sport which is kind of on
the decline to get more people
interested
but um I'll answer any questions if
anyone has any
thank you any questions
representative Smith thank you Mr
chairman
wouldn't it be safe to say that
um hand catching a lobster is a I think
you acknowledge there's a less passive a
more passive way of capturing a lobster
and the probability of bycatch
unlike Nets which catch numerous other
marine species is is basically not going
to happen
if I understand your question correct
yes it is much more Passive by by scuba
but
um as opposed to other means which catch
by catch
um and as a diver I see all the time
fish in pots they get in but they can't
get out caught and so and as a dive
you're not supposed to touch the pots
you can look at them but there's you
can't let them out
um even lobsters get in there I know
that smaller ones can get in and out but
reality a lot of them get in there and
then there's storms and the way that the
pot gets mangled um some of the the exit
points are blocked
um so they're there and I see them all
the time as and I've seen
uh dead lobsters and you know four pound
Lobster that's about 40 000 eggs there's
the rule of thumb is like I think 10 000
eggs per pound so you're talking when
you especially if it's an eggger it does
have an impact
um so that's something that's to
consider one other thing I do this
organization that we brought up called
oceans wide I do volunteer for
um it's a non-profit in Maine and we
actually go out and clear and look for
abandoned pots and and um you'll see
there's a video that was sent on it pots
that we identify that are identified
um that get brought up they have tags
and those tags identify the owner so the
owner gets those pots back they're
contacted hey your pot was found it's
there if you want it come and get it if
you don't those that don't want them
they usually give them to Apprentice uh
Lobster Harvesters that are just
starting out
thank you any other questions
Madam Clerk
thank you I actually have two questions
one is on a process that Committee in
previous years had heard uh an
accusation that some divers catch
Lobster by the claw my understanding is
that claws usually become unattached in
that situation so I don't really know
why a diver would do that so maybe you
can clarify what we've heard in the past
and and what divers actually do
yeah they're an inexperienced diver
might be trying to get a these lobsters
are their tails in their back in the
hole and the claws are out there
um the last thing a diver wants the last
thing you want to do is grab a lobster
by the clock because what will happen is
the claw is going to come off
so what if that Lobster is a short or
egg bearing you're going to put it back
you can't bring it up so and and the
other thing is that
as a you know when you bring up a
Lobster Claw even if it's a legal
Lobster and you bring it up and it's in
the claw it just gets bad after it has
to be attached by the time you get home
and it's just not as good so that's part
of it but it's really just it's not a
good practice to do it so
um through training and education there
are proper ways to get at it and and the
way is you put your hand over the
carpatch and grab it from the body but
and you can even tell if it's a mold
when you're in there you'll know that oh
it's mulch so you're not going to want
to bring that up that just means that it
just recently shed its skin and it's
very soft and
um those aren't that means they're not
really good lobsters to take because
they're there's not a whole lot of meat
you want the ones that that are not mold
so these are things that you can tell
when you're grabbing or fishing looking
for them as opposed to bring them up
through a non-pot license
follow-up
thank you
um also is it true that when you use a
boat to capture Lobster then in fact
there are different fish species and
schools of fish that have learned to
follow the boats specifically because
the bycatch gets thrown off the edge and
so in that water column those Lobster
whether they're Eggers whether they're
other species whatever may have been
caught indiscriminately are not just
generally susceptible to Predators but
very specifically susceptible to the
Predators that have learned to follow
those boats absolutely you're absolutely
correct especially striped bass which
during the season they're going after uh
that's their one of their primary uh
food sources yes
thank you any other questions
yes uh representative Ming
uh thank you um
uh scuba certification is that a
requirement in the state of New
Hampshire that is correct uh for what
for this bill divers have to be divers
have to be certified to to do that yes
okay thank you
thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
customers
the chair now calls Ward Byrne
it was asked for two minutes
thank you for your time this morning
um I've already heard a lot of uh
good testimony from uh Mr Anderson and
I feel like I've heard a lot of faults
uh guesstimate scientific data that
really is Hocus Pocus in this room
and uh you some may find that offending
but that's uh my experience on the water
and no one knows the ocean better than
the guys that make the living there
um this business of derelict gear is is
just not true any gear that's derelict
is usually in Shore water and ends up on
Route 1 after a winter storm and it's
cleaned up and gone and our New
Hampshire lobster industry does clean
that up
um I think Cherie Patterson could
clarify the number of tonnage of rope
and lobster gear that is recovered by
the New Hampshire lobster industry and
it is quite significant
um nothing that's been brought up here
this morning is the potential of theft
of a say diver that goes down and is
come from say Pittsburgh to go diving
and he can't find his lobsters but he
finds my lobster trap or traps
watch to prevent him
from going in my trap and taking my
catch the answer is nothing
because fish and games made it clear
that they can't enforce it
and I we can talk about
um
studies and and some of the information
they've given you this morning is if you
look at it and read it the piles of
traps those are from Nova Scotia not New
Hampshire state waters
I got a brief look at them so it's
irrelevant to what happens in our Waters
okay
I I feel as though as a fisherman this
is a huge enforcement problem
to prevent anybody from stealing from me
as this is my living I have a son that's
also a commercial fisherman
it's his living
you know I I can understand how they
want to dive on the law offices and it
sounds fun and everything and
you could have
10 honest fishermen Lobster fishermen
diving and now we get another 80 out
there that is stealing from us and I I
have a real problem with that again I
think fishing game is going to speak
heavily on this the enforcement end of
it how it is not possible to enforce
what goes on under the water thank you
thank you for your testimony and
the chair will now call
Grand Birch who's asked for 10 minutes
and it says you have written testimony
if you would uh
pass that into the clerk when you're
done we will make sure that gets around
to everyone
could you please turn your mic on
there we go thank you so Mr chairman
members of committee thank you for the
opportunity to speak to you this morning
my name is Graham Burch I live in Hollis
New Hampshire
I say that just so that you're not
thrown by my funny accent and think that
I come from strange places I've lived
there for 26 years my wife and I have
raised our four kids in uh in Hollis
um
I'm a Avid scuba diver in my uh Spare
Time little Lloyd is and uh one of the
things I do is is I teach scuba diving
so I'm a I'm an instructor
um
question was asked previously about
scuba certification I'm one of those
people who brings in an interested party
someone that's never been diving before
and trains them in the sport educates
them and teaches them about dive safety
and how to dive particularly in our
called New Hampshire Waters and be safe
while doing it
incidentally not German to my testimony
but as a part of that training we do
also instruct divers on how to behave
around Lobster gear which in the state
of New Hampshire currently and hopefully
for the foreseeable future is you steer
clear of it
you can't avoid it
um you know we dive in waters we have a
visibility of around you know a good day
10 feet
um so we're always swimming in around
the same areas that the commercial
lobsterman are fishing in and that
really brings me to the core point of my
testimony today and I'd like to speak
about the important issue of safety
as a diver and as an instructor
responsible for students safety is of
utmost concern to me and we've heard
this morning
um you know at least one I would say
hyperbole around enormous consequences
for safety
I think we have to match hyperbole with
facts and so what I'd like to give you
is four facts on the topic of safety
that should just put this one to bed
so firstly
as I mentioned previously divers are
already in the waters where lobsterman
are fishing that's where we dive we
don't dive off Hampton Beach where it's
Sandy because there's frankly nothing to
look at we die where it's Rocky that's
where the critters are that's where it's
fun to dive that's where we see all the
amazing wildlife and that's also where
the lobster and fish so we co-exist and
have been coexisting for decades with uh
with lobsterman and as I say we swim
past the gear on virtually every dive
Point number two
there are no safety
incidents involving divers and lobster
gear documented anywhere in the New
England region despite the fact that
we're all sharing the same waterways
there's nothing on
their dive related sites non-diver
related government websites or even the
widely respected divers alert Network
annual diving incident reports none of
them report any safety related concerns
or incidents involving divers and active
lobstermen using the same Waters so
Point number one we share the waters
Point number two
there's no problem
Point number three
if if there were to be such a problem
then we would find it probably in our
neighbor instead of Massachusetts
right where divers are allowed to take
lobsters and share the same Waters with
the lobsterman but again there are no
reported incidents of conflicts safety
related conflicts between divers and
lobstermen so it really is it's a moot
point
and then point number four uh there was
a question raised about well maybe if we
open up lobstering to divers that would
bring a flood of divers into the waters
therefore increase in the number of
divers therefore potentially increasing
the number of um of incidents
if we look at this I think I think
currently the bill says something
recommends something like a hundred
licenses
so worst case scenario
if that were to mean 100 new certified
divers in our Waters
that would barely bring the number of
divers back to the level of the number
of divers that were diving probably you
know five and ten years ago the scuba
diving industry is is in Decline number
of divers are in Decline and that's
measured by the number of dive shops
that have gone out of business over the
last few years and the number of boats
that have uh stopped running dive
charters
so even if there was a small influx of
new divers um that will not move the
needle in terms of safety so that's the
end of my testimony I just like to
summarize and say I think there are four
not hyperbole not arm waving
um not what ifs just four clear facts
that we already share the waters there
is no safety concern here in New
Hampshire there is no safety concern in
Massachusetts where we there is such a
light an ability to take lobsters and
lastly even if there is a small growth
in the dive industry we wouldn't get
back to the numbers we were at a few
years ago when we all shared the waters
quite safely
so thank you very much for your time I'm
happy to take any questions
thank you uh Madam Clerk
thank you for your testimony and thank
you for taking my question
um we heard just a few minutes ago
testimony saying that if we allow these
licenses that the divers would be
illegally stealing out of traps but as
you just said divers are already and
have been for decades coexisting in the
same Waters is there anything preventing
them from stealing out of traps now what
is what is the issue with that I don't
understand what's preventing that now
yeah what's so here's a a thin line
what's prevented is the morality of the
divers and the training
so we uh you know we train we teach we
educate
um divers are very concerned for The
Aquatic environment
um and absolutely concerned that the um
you know for the prosperity and the
longevity of the the lobstermen and
their uh their industry
could you stop it 100 I wish I could say
we could but you know what there's
always maybe going to be a bad apple I
couldn't really say
um but do I think it will be prevalent
not from the divers that I know or meet
with regularly as I'm diving The Shores
At the weekends
follow-up
thank you
um and also we heard you talk about how
this bill does require certification I
am not certified In Scuba
um my understanding it's a fairly
expensive and involved process would
someone can you foresee somebody going
through the process of becoming
certified in order to catch an
occasional Lobster
just to capture the cables no it'd be
much cheaper to go buy one for dinner
any other questions
representative Smith thank you Mr
chairman I do agree with the previous
representative this is a nation on the
presumption of innocence most people are
good and you can't always uh create a
rule to prevent the Bad Apple from
acting uh my question is
and maybe this is a question for the law
enforcement Colonel that's going to
probably come up and speak but what
would be the difference between
enforcing the diving for lobster and
saying enforcing fishing regulations
because both of the catch have to be
brought up on shore of the boat where
then Fish and Game can then conduct
proper enforcement so I don't see the
issue with that
yeah I think it's a great question
um I don't feel like I'm the probably
the right rightly qualified person to
answer that question but it's a very
good question
thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
chair will call Jean Marconi
who's asked for three minutes
good morning excuse me Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is Geno
Marconi and I am the chairman of the
advisory committee on marine fisheries
which is established under RSA 211 colon
60. uh the committee is made up of a
diverse group of people
that are involved in the marine
environment a commercial fishermen a
recreational fishermen chatter boat
fishermen
Marine wholesale dealers
and uh we've got a pro a lot a broad
experience of folks on that committee
and I'll preface my remarks by saying
that last year when this bill came came
before the legislature the committee did
meet with a group of divers
uh and we had a great discussion about
it but I'm here to tell you today that
the committee has voted unanimously to
oppose the taking of lobsters by scuba
I've handed out a letter for the sake of
those folks behind me I'm going to keep
it real short and sweet
Lobster is one of the most highly
regulated species in the Gulf of Maine
and in the state of New Hampshire and
the regulations that we have today
are equal to all citizens of the State
of New Hampshire in order to harvest
lobsters buy a method that is proven to
be over many years of research proven to
be protective of that species in the
methods in which it's harvested
um it it's on an equal basis and it's
limited to taking of lobsters by Parts
Only
um
yes there is some disparity maybe that's
not the correct word there are some
issues with law enforcement and as
representative Smith raised the question
the only time that the law enforcement
can Chuck these lobsters is when they're
brought to the surface
this bill would allow scuba or divers or
swimmers for that matter to possess that
Lobster it does not give away for law
enforcement to inspect what goes on
under the water
I've been around the Waterfront a long
time we work very closely with the fish
and game department
guide digging clams you can observe them
from the shore at a distance a guy
hauling lobster traps you can observe
him from a distance everything is done
above the water The Taking of lobsters
under the water there's no way to
observe it maybe the Navy has technology
to observe these things but I don't
think we do
I would ask you again for the sake of
brevity please please read that what the
committee has authorized me to bring to
you I will just say one thing about
ghost traps and that is that uh
they do
do a Trap clean up every year and in my
experience diving I have not witnessed
big mounds of lobster traps on the ocean
on on in the coastal Waters of New
Hampshire are out at the aisles of
Shoals I I've never seen it
um
as far as retrieving those ghost traps
any person that dives that wants to be
environmentally conscious
should mock the location of those traps
if they see them contact contact fishing
game department in the fish and game
department I'm sure would make
plans to go and have those lobster traps
or treat retrieved I don't think giving
someone a license to harvest the lobster
is predicated on them being
environmentally conscious to go find
lost a gear again Mr chairman there are
a lot of other people that are more
qualified than me to be here and I'll
leave it at that
thank you are there any questions
Mr Vice chair
thank you Mr chairman could you tell me
is there currently any funding source or
a fund available to clean up
these straps
there is now yes if I may just follow up
to that prior to that there was some
grant money that came out of sea Grant
at the University of New Hampshire and
the other hat that I representative is I
do
work at the Port Authority and we manage
the facilities at Ryan Hampton and in
the commercial fish pier in Portsmouth
we've contributed to that over the years
by providing a payment for dumpsters
that's been our contribution to this so
I do see a lot of the stuff that's done
during the Trap cleanup but there was
that fund that was established and yes
and thank you for the liberty of
responding
any other questions
representative Ford
thank you Mr chair I just want to make
sure I'm clear on on the committee's
opposition to this particular Bill uh
they're opposed to the hand collection
of the lobster but if a scuba diver
wants to use the the traps or the pots
that's okay with the committee
like if the individual's a scuba diver
they want to get a license from Fish and
Game and go out and do the small what is
it five whatever for a prairie season or
whatever you're with that but not hand
collection which are some of the other
representative there are a lot of people
that I know that scuba dive that have
commercial Lobster licenses but they
only Harvest by using lobster traps yes
sir thank you
Madam Clerk
thank you for your testimony and thank
you for taking my question just to be
very clear I want the committee's
objection is to the enforcement or
enforceability of this it's not that
you're saying that the enforceability in
terms of the legal Lobster itself is
unenforceable because that can be
observed above water so am I right in
understanding that the objection is to
the idea that take that specifically the
idea of divers stealing out of traps is
the part that you find to be
unenforceable
the harvesting of the creature
underwater we believe is unenforceable
The Possession anyone anyone in
possession of a lobster if I if I go to
Walmart and I buy a lobster out of the
tank and I'm walking out the door and I
run into the game wide in the parking
lot and we're shooting the breeze and my
bag Falls open and he looks at the
lobster and he sees wow that doesn't
it's got eggs on it that's a violation
state law possession and I could be
wrong
Colonel if if
it's illegal to possess a lobster that
doesn't meet the specification set forth
in the code of administrative rules
follow up
I'm afraid I don't think that answered
my question my question is
which thing are we talking about it's
being unenforceable because if Fish and
Game can Patrol any other species above
the water including Lobster so they can
enforce the in terms of the lobster
being a legal take the right size not
neggar Etc that's already that that
would be enforceable under this but
specifically your committee is objecting
to the enforceability of stealing from
traps the method in which it's harvested
which could include poaching from
lobsters yes
any other questions
representative Smith thank you Mr
chairman I just want to follow up on rep
Reed's comments again
we need to not lose that the presumption
of innocence most people are good and
they're out there doing their daily
lives in a honorable way I just want to
compare the idea of catching Lobster by
hand on the water it's no different than
a hunter I hunt I hike eight ten miles
through the back Woods fishing game
cannot watch everything I do every day
as I hunt people harvest deer every day
outside of the site a fishing game so
the idea that someone's swimming for
lobster and catching catching capturing
them
without the eyes of fishing game on that
action is is just not a good comparison
Representatives their question there do
you yes do you believe that it's any
different harvesting lobster under the
water than it is for a hunter harvesting
a deer in the back of the mountains
where there are no fish and game present
I think those are two scenarios that
cannot be compared I think there's
difference day and night that's my
opinion
any other questions
representative Brown
thank you Mr chairman for taking my
question
how are you I'm doing well sir nice to
see you nice to be seen
um
you may not be the person to answer this
but because you have this Association
maybe you have a feel for it uh I think
uh Graham Burch mentioned that he
doesn't believe that
scuba diving interferes with lobstering
as a general rule
um if you add some amount of scuba
divers to a lobstering area do you think
that that's true
would you agree that the lobstering
community would say that scuba divers
don't interfere with their business
any comment to that representative would
be is
um there's a reason why the lobster
traps it is that's because that's what
the lobsters are
thank you
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you sir and thank you
members of the committee
the chair calls David Coyle
hello my name is David Coyle one of our
aquatic Specialties Merrimack New
Hampshire the reason I got involved in
this was because
I dive a lot I teach about 100
certifications a year I'm involved with
the diving community and
my father was a lobsterman I'm in
construction it's not an easy business
we're not here to take their livelihood
it's just that when I take out students
and I'm diving and I see Lobster pots
and I see animals inside that I cannot
touch their Lobster Pot I can't remove
that animal because it is unlawful to do
so I'm the people that I'm the person
talking to them and explaining that to
them
and I I come to these meetings and I
feel that there's an embossity against
the lobster men and the divers we need
to change that not every diver is out
there going out and stealing lobsters
we're out there every weekend I was out
last weekend we're diving with four
people we're diving out because we want
to take pictures we want to see things
we want to improve our Waters we have
created a lot of ecology programs that
are helping educate and
awareness and that's what I like to do
about this is I like to help educate and
aware that is that not every diver out
there is out there because I'm diving
next to a Lobster Pot and I have a buoy
they can see my buoy go and buy their
buoys that I am stealing their lobster
pots wouldn't it be better to have a
system in place that we can monitor it I
have a program that I've created it's
called the weed control diver and this
is just basically the program of what
the class is the weed control diver is a
class that we take to be able to remove
milfoil correctly in New Hampshire it's
been working for a number of years there
is a sign up sheet when you can take the
class there is student material for them
to be able to take this is my PowerPoint
presentation there's a test in there we
can have all of the education that is
concerned for divers that are out there
if we were to take lobsters so that's
what's got me involved in this is is
that I would like to help educate people
that are diving and make sure that if we
are going to create something that we're
doing it properly this is my concern
okay
um the um I just I I feel there's a lot
of emosity between the two and I think
that that should be relieved and I think
by having it being legal and having them
come back and actually show your catch
and being able to you know you say you
can't see it underwater but have a
um a way that we can Market it we can
take a print a picture or we have a
station that just like when we're
hunting for deer right or you're hunting
for anything you have a station that you
have to take it to it I'm happy to work
with Fish and Game to be able to create
a program to be able to have that in
place we already have something that
works with the weed control diver and I
think that's something that we could do
to change the future for New Hampshire
Waterworks
thank you are there any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
is that a handout for us or this is my
whole program what I did is I just
printed the whole thing off so that you
could be able to see it if you can give
that to the clerk we'll have copies made
thank you okay yeah it was too much for
everybody
the chair now calls Bobby nudd
who's asked for three minutes
thank you
Mr chairman members of the committee
my name is Bobby nugg I live in Hampton
New Hampshire
and I first of all I'd like to preface
my testimony here by saying that I
crafted this testimony before there were
any amendments to
uh this bill so I'm going to continue
and please bear with me
my name is Bobby Nutt
my family has fished the Waters of the
State of New Hampshire for 380 years
as for myself I have been a commercial
fisherman in this state for 49 years
I'm in the New Hampshire Fisheries
representative on the Atlantic states
marine fisheries commission Lobster
Advisory Board
I am also a member of the Atlantic the
Atlantic Lodge whale take reduction team
and I stand opposed to this bill as it's
written
the lobster resource in the Gulf of
Maine is one of the healthiest and
sustainable resources that still exists
that's not by accident
we don't harvest the small lobsters we
protect The Brood stock by not taking
the large ones
we protect the females with eggs and the
females who have had eggs in the past
our traps have bio biodegradable Escape
panels
to allow
small
excuse me
while small lobsters and other species
to escape
if a trap is lost
the biodegradable event will over time
open to allow anything remaining to
escape
with limit effort through trap caps
and what will return to the ocean we do
so alive
we'll reduce risk to marine mammals
through closures weak lines and other
gear modifications
our traps for all practical purposes are
dinosaurs
the basic design except for resource
friendly modifications has not changed
in over 100 years
the Trap fishery is opportunistic
lobsters are not forced to enter
they only enter when they want to
when they are mating bedding or inactive
they are not forced into a trap
in addition the lobster fishery of this
state contributes millions of dollars to
the economy
like any other users of the ocean
commercial and recreational alike
including recreational hook and line
fishermen and boaters we occasionally
lose gear to Mother Nature
we have for years cleaned the coast of
traps and fishing gear which is washed
ashore
we have also discouraged the abandonment
of and non-tending of lobster gear
through laws and penalties
if our gear and nothing of fishing is
detrimental to the resource it would be
hard to explain why the largest resource
in the Gulf of Maine is the healthiest
related fishery that still exists
The Fishery is given by governed by laws
designed to guarantee the sustainability
of the resource for current and future
Generations
the laws although state laws called
state laws are actually generated by the
Atlantic states marine fisheries
Commission
all Lobster producing states with a few
exceptions based on conservation
equivalency or historical practices
abide by the same laws
laws in federal waters are adopted from
Atlantic states marine fisheries
Commission
like everywhere they are only effective
with compliance and enforcement
there are no laws they're effective
without these two components
to try to tie the hands of law
enforcement is unexcusutable
every Lobster producing state works with
national marine fisheries service and
the U.S Coast Guard to enforce lobsters
in federal waters
it's important to remember that federal
waters is just a lie on a chart
the fishermen in this case are New
Hampshire fishermen regardless of where
they fish and much of New Hampshire
lobster fishery is conducted in federal
waters
the prohibition on the use of State
resources
what does that mean does that mean that
mandatory reporting by federally
primitive vessels as required by the
Atlantic states marine fisheries
commission can no longer be kept by
national by New Hampshire Fish and Game
does that mean that the issuance of trap
tags to federally permitted vessels can
no longer be part of the state trap tag
system
does that mean it mandates Under The
Endangered Species Act and the Marine
Mammal protection act which go into
state waters cannot be enforced by
Naturally by New Hampshire Fish and Game
the implications of this kind of
prohibition are enormous and totally
unwarranted
as a member of the Atlantic Lodge whale
take reduction team I and the other
members other New Hampshire members on
that team have spent hundreds of hours
in the last year working to reduce risk
to right whales by 90 percent
while being sure that New Hampshire
lobster Fisher remains intact for the
current and future Generations
that has not been an easy task not when
the neighbors our neighbors want to
reduce our traps by 50 and close our
fishery for five months a year
in these negotiations compliance
enforcement is always of great concern
if I go to the trt and say these rules
are all well and good but New Hampshire
is not going to enforce them
the results would be catastrophic
Under The Marine Mammal protection act
and The Endangered Species Act The
Fishery in this state could be shut down
as simple as that
and for those who say it can't happen
let me assure you it can happen and has
happened in other states
as for the diving part of this bill I
will leave that to the others except to
say that under G in the proposed bill
uh
RSA
21162 and RSA 211 27 stay Nothing At All
About The Taking of big bearing females
which is irsa to 1126 it says nothing
about scrubbing Eggers which is RSA
21125 or v-notch lobsters and mutilated
Tails which is FSI 206-11
as far as a physical impact of this bill
I take exception with the 10 10 000
determination
if the lobster fishery in this state is
closed for non-compliance the impact
would be in the millions yearly
and I'd like to thank you for listening
to my concerns probably not
thank you are there any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
oh wait we have one menu recognized
thank you Mr chair
um Mr nut I was just hoping you could
give us a snapshot of the lobster
industry in New Hampshire who are the
smallest who are the biggest what's the
average
excuse me I'm sorry I don't hear very
well
yes I was hoping you could give give us
a snapshot of what the lobster industry
looks like in New Hampshire
what do the smallest outfits look like
what do the big operations look like
what is typical
again I didn't get I'm sorry I didn't
get the question can you can you
he's asking you
um if you could please provide a
snapshot of what the industry looks like
in New Hampshire for lobstering
um what what is the size of a small
operation what are the largest
operations like and what's a typical
operation or an average one in the state
uh the uh the lobster fishery in the
State uh is an owner for the most part
actually it is they're all that I can
remember is an owner operator uh Fishery
uh it's relatively small the majority of
fishermen in this state fish 600 or less
traps
um
the range of the fishery in state waters
obviously is in state waters
there are uh
portion of the state fishermen who have
federally permitted vessels
uh the
it's a small fishery compared to other
states compared to other states uh the
size of the boat
uh probably is
half the size
and we have a very large fishery a very
large portion of our fishery is
very small boat fishery retired people
that fish are only a handful of traps
out of small boats right on the coast
hope that answers your question
thank you that does thank you
any other questions
seeing none thank you thank you very
much
the chair calls Bill Marconi
does not say whether you support or
oppose the bill on here
my name's uh Bill Marconi
uh I've been fishing lobstering for 50
years
in 100 of my income is Lobster's that's
it
um you guys talk about safety
it's safe it is a problem it's a problem
now I fish uh in the river along the
shore all the way up to
boy's head in
there's times you got to really watch
what you're doing
and it you know we see the dive Flags
yeah we be careful but
in the summertime
when we're fishing along the shore
we're all trying to get the same spot
because the lobsters are in certain
places so we're tight our trolls a tight
to each other without getting on each
other
so what I'm saying is it's a very busy
place and now if you have a diver in
there
I'm you know I'm worried I mean on
weekends
in the last 10 or 15 years this area is
off of Newcastle I don't I try not to
haul there on Saturday or Sunday I try
to haul on Friday there because of the
boat traffic you got boat traffic now
you've got
possible divers it I'm surprised nobody
no one's gotten hurt yet
so I think the die the safety thing
is is going to be a problem the
enforcement I mean that's obvious
I mean you think about it I mean if I'm
a diver you know a diver could be down
there he ain't seeing no lobsters and
there's my trap and there's you know
Jesus it's nice one there
game one is can't prevent that from
happening you know I mean I know there
could be good ones and bad ones but it's
awful tempting
uh
in you know that one of the divers said
this you know they see a lot of Eggers
and stuff yeah he sees a lot of Eggers
we're mocking these lobsters we're
farming these things
we've been we've been we get a lot so a
shot Lobster with eggs on it we mock it
put a notch in the tail we throw it back
that loss is protected
there's a lot of them yeah well because
what what we're produced we're making
that happen
so what we our traps have vents in them
for all the little ones get out and then
the bio event the the Trap gets lost it
I have to put new uh steel uh hog rings
in every like eight nine months they
brushed out and if I don't the the the
the these bio events open up the
everything gets out of that trap so we
try to keep up on it ghost gear there's
no there's no lobsters in them if I find
a a lost trap it's the vents flapping as
though there's nothing in there
and they you know people were talking
about
um you know going nice to grab a lobster
you know underneath a rock and stuff
well that's that's the natural bottom we
have the last thing you probably want to
do is start lifting rocks and moving
stuff I mean that's the natural thing we
have we have here
in in a natural way to catch a lopsis in
a trap you know
and somebody mentioned 10 percent of
gear is lost every year
I don't know about that I fished 1200
traps if I lost 120 traps my traps are
150 at 175 dollars a piece that's a lot
of money
so this lost gear thing you know we if
we lose a trap we lose gear we grapple
them up you know we we don't just oh I
lost it forget about it it's just too
much money there's a lot of money in
this business we've put in you know I've
I've been doing it my son now is doing
it and you know we've built this whole
state has built a nice a nice business
and we're farming these lobsters we're
not you know the way we're doing it it's
producing you know future losses for
future fishermen
in and they want to do April April we a
lot of guys set out in April
that's beginning of the season for a lot
of guys
in in we fish along the shore April to
September a lot of guys are fishing
right along the shore where the divers
are going to be you know so
um
in my other thought was
this state has a license for anybody can
catch a lot it can buy fire traps
anybody can do it and it can be
inexpensive if you want it to be I I see
a lot of people
take their boats on the weekends to psi
when they put the boat in the water they
have five traps they go out and haul the
traps and have fun and they and they're
not just to get their offices and
everybody's happy and in that way the
game the game one is going to force it
they can see what they're doing
underwater nobody can enforce it
um it's about all I have
thank you uh Madam Clerk
thank you for your testimony and thank
you for taking my question my question
is I heard a little bit of conflicting
information on the one hand you said if
there's divers now going to catch
Lobster that that would present an extra
security problem or a safety problem
rather but you prefaced all of that by
saying that you run into the divers all
the time you see their Flags it's a very
crowded busy place to use your words I
know because I had to type them so
um so if you're already running into so
many and encountering so many divers I
don't understand you can you explain to
me how having some of those divers
license to take Lobster by hand presents
an increased security or science keeps
saying security safety problem
yeah because you're going to have more
divers right where the lobster gear is
that's I mean if you're diving for
lobsters you're going to go with will we
go and you're going to have more of them
around us
and it's it's gonna it's a safety thing
I mean the last thing I want to do is
you know run you know run one of these
guys over
um
I hope that answers that I don't know if
it did or not but thank you
representative
thank you for taking my question
um my question is I had heard
um Through the Grapevine
somebody had mentioned to me that
lobstering companies and people may have
some sort of insurance on their gear and
it could be implied that sometimes
there could be incentive for those two
who need more gear to lose the old gear
so that the insurance could cover New
Gear I don't know I have no experience
in the lobstering industry I don't know
if this insurance exists if it only
exists for people who can pay it
wouldn't affect here or what have you I
wanted to know if you had any insight on
how much that kind of claim has bearings
in reality for insurances to sort of
have
lobsters incentivized to lose their gear
yeah
um I I'm not aware of any in any
insurance
you know for for this I mean I have boat
insurance but uh as far as gear
insurance I I'm not aware of it
I can't imagine
what that would even entail well like I
say
you know my I my traps 150 a piece and
this isn't something that you you're
careless about
I lose it I mean if we spend hours
grappling for gear if we lose one it's
not like you lose it and forget about it
no I don't think
I don't think there's the the ghost
gears out there like everybody thinks
there is any gear along the shore that
every spring we have a spring cleanup
and we and we pick them up no gear stays
the ocean gets so rough no gas stays
lost along the shore
thank you representative Ford thank you
Mr chair and thank you for coming down
you said 100 of your income is from this
job and I appreciate you taking the time
to come speak with us today about it
um I have a question about the time
frame in which the licenses could be out
and divers can be in
um in your opinion do you think a short
amount of time or a more specific time
would be adequate for the safety issues
because
um as representative Reed said stated
um you know there's lots of people out
there and I too are thinking about those
who of us who hibernate in the winter
and only come out when it's really warm
out those months that are listed in the
bill would be the time that a lot of
people are just out near the water in
general swimming just out by the beach
scuba divers your work
um is there what in your opinion do you
think a shorter amount of time for a
scuba divers to be out there would be
helpful or
um be a good modification yeah
yeah I
like I said April a lot of the guys are
setting out and
there's no there's gear along that show
people we people catch lobsters along
that Shore right up until you know
Christmas
um
even longer but I'm just saying in that
time frame that's a there's a lot of it
so the commercial a lot of guys have
efficient along that Shore I mean it's
if the lobsters if the losses are there
you're not going to leave you know I
mean so if his loss is there we're going
to try to catch him
so I don't know if that really helped
you
but I mean it helped me understand the
issue thank you I appreciate it thank
you representative Brown
uh thank you Mr chairman take my
question I'll follow up I want to ask
chairman Marconi maybe you can answer
this
do you foresee that
there will be more divers in the area
where you're working and then that will
make your day less productive because
you have to wait until they're out of
the way is it this area that's a great
question there's areas by the mouth of
the harbor that I get a holy haul there
at slack water
the tide runs so high to pull the buoys
under
the last thing I want to do is I got
probably a two and a half hour time
frame to get so much gear Haul is wait
for a diver to come up
yeah it could present a problem
you know it's
follow-up and and maybe this is a
comment more than a question
the divers have that same time frame to
work because of the title effects right
or unless maybe even I don't know I'm
assuming I'm assuming I don't know what
what it's I I'm not a diver okay so I I
can't answer that
thank you any other questions
Madam Clark
thank you for taking another question
you mentioned grappling for lost gear
um I guess it's a bit of a two-part
question when you grapple for lost gear
um I presume you have a pretty good
indication of where those traps are and
so you know where to Grapple and
secondly is dragging a grapple hook
damaging to the the floor
yeah we know exactly where the traps are
the GPS systems we have now are are real
accurate so normally uh we can throw the
hook over and make a couple of passes
and get it the hook that we have is a
small uh hook that would would is
designed to to snag a rope so I don't
believe it's it's you ruining the bottom
there again
we don't lose that much gear Mo all
these guys behind me we all we fish on a
regular basis we don't
we keep up on our buoys we keep up on
everything so it's not like none of
these guys are just going to leave gear
in the water everybody's everybody's uh
conscious of what we're doing
thank you
seeing no further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you the chair
calls Jim tetoni
hope I pronounced that right
you did request 10 minutes I hope that
in the interest of time we can do it a
little less than that
thank you
good afternoon my name is Jim tatone I'm
from Seabrook
I'm here today on behalf of the more
than 60 members of the Yankee
Fisherman's co-op in Seabrook who are in
opposition to house bill 442.
uh lobsters are a finite resource now
that's not a statement I made up that
was come right from our own lead Lobster
science scientist Josh colony who works
for the New Hampshire Fish and Game
So based upon that
sustainability of this Lobster resources
of Paramount importance
lobsterman understand this and
lobsterman are going to do what they
need to do to keep this
fishery this resource sustainable in
order to continue their livelihoods now
there's been a lot of research conducted
about
traps and their their role in the whole
process of sustainability
um Josh kaloni of the New Hampshire
fishing game as well as a Dr Robert
stennick the University of Maine's
Lobster Institute have conducted a lot
of research and determined that the
lobster trap is the main source of food
supply for the lobsters
and also Dr stenick said with this in
mind
the lobster trap fishery is the largest
aquaculture process in the world because
basically we're spending a lot of money
on bait
the bait in the traps is attracting the
lobsters the lapses eat they can get out
96 percent of the lobsters to get into a
trap Escape
so we're only catching basically four
percent of the lobsters
now
on the thing of cost of bait
last year debate is very expensive last
year one third of my gross Lobster
income went to the expenditure of bait
and all this is like an investment in
this resource to keep it healthy
scuba taking the Lobsters by scuba
diving does not contribute to the
sustainability of the resource
there's no investment by divers to keep
this resource healthy
the other thing we've got there's a big
storm coming up here in the lobster
industry right now The Landings are good
it's the Calm before the storm
Dr Richard Wally who is the director of
the lobster Institute for the state of
Maine in 1989 he came he devised this
sampling system where they go around
sample the amount of juvenile lobsters
that are actually settling to the bottom
right now there's approximately 62
sampling sites from Newfoundland and
Canada all the way down to Long Island
where they sample the amount of juvenile
lobsters that are settling to the bottom
and because of the global global warming
conditions the Gulf of Maine is warming
faster than any other body of water on
Earth
and this warming water is affecting the
ability of the juveniles to survive in
order to settle to the bottom
in 2021 there was a 23 percent decline
in the number of juvenile warpses that
settled to the bottom of the ocean
that's just
23 from the year prior
the concern here is that and I'm going
to quote Josh colony from the fish and
game
if consecutive years of poor juvenile
recruitment occur
decline in the number of juvenile oh
wait a minute it could it could
dramatically impact the sustainability
of the lobster population this is
actually happening well offices don't
become legal until between five and
seven years so this storm was not
hitting now it's going to be hitting in
the future so here we are talking about
allowing an activity that does not
contribute to the sustainability of the
lobster resource to allow them to take
our resource and not provide any
investment in this
now we've I've heard a lot of
conversation this morning about
ghost gear and how much uh that that's
affected
I I've been fishing for over 50 years
and over that period of time I've seen a
lot of stuff going on out in the ocean
I've had traps ghost traps come up
entangled in my gear and on one occasion
have I've seen
a lobster in any of these ghost traps
that have come up the biodegradable
Escape vents are effective they are
working
the enforcement part of it that's been
hashed out here we can observe any
violations that could be occurring above
the surface of the water we have
visibility from not only fish and game
but from other fishermen
if there's another fisherman here
see somebody messing around with my gear
they're going to alert me to that so we
have more than fish and game alerting
people to the possibilities of
violations above the surface of the
water
below the surface of the water there's
there's no enforcement no
certain times of the year I'm fishing
really tight in in in coastal Waters I
mean sometimes less than 10 feet of
water
and I've had traps rated by divers
a friend of mine who passed away a few
years ago Bob Littlefield one of the
highliners he would fish uh Place coven
Hampton pretty steadily and he
continuously had problems with divers so
to try to eliminate the issue of divers
getting into his traps he hog-ringed his
doors shut to prevent them from being
open
but what's happening with the divers
they were slicing the twine hinges on
his traps folding his doors open and
then slicing the heads in the traps to
get access to his lopsis so it did
definitely a problem with traps being
rated because the lobster trap is the
main source of supply for the lobsters
so lops is basically hang out in and
around traps it'd be very tempting if
you're not finding lobsters in their
natural habitat the best place to find
them is in a trap
now one other thing about this bill this
language in there that states the
executive director is going to set aside
protected zones
for the activity of scuba dime for
lobsters what I interpret this to mean
is this zone is going to be protected
strictly for the diving activity so
basically grounds that I have
traditionally fished I may be shut out
of for an activity that's not
contributing to the sustainability of
this this resource and this just isn't
right another issue I've heard been
hearing is that the cost of Entry
everybody in this room
can exploit the lobster resource but
what we ask is that it be exploited in a
manner that's sustainable and that's
through the Trap fishery the cost of
entry for diving which I've researched
is comparable to what it would take to
purchase a boat motor and trailer so it
is no excuse why people can't
exploit the resource through the Trap
fishery and again
I I don't think this is I don't believe
that we should allow
an activity which doesn't contribute to
the
the resource to be allowed to be partake
in the taking of these lobsters so
that's my testimony if anybody's any
questions I'll be more than happy that
answer thank you much uh any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
the chair calls Sherry Patterson
you've requested 10 minutes if you could
keep it under that that would be great
and Colonel Jordan I have your card two
are you going to be testifying jointly
you can be yeah I think that'll be
easier then I'll take your card out of
the pile and give it right here
thank you very much that'll help with
our time issue as well
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Cherie Patterson I'm the chief of marine
fisheries for the fish and game
department
The Fish and Game Commission voted has
voted to oppose House Bill 442
relative to special licenses for taking
Lobster while engaged in recreational
scuba diving
New Hampshire's Lobster fishery is the
state's most valuable commercial fishery
contributing more than 34 million
dollars annually in Revenue to the more
than 330 licensed commercial Harvesters
certain economic models suggest the
overall contribution to New Hampshire's
economy is likely three to four times
that amount to roughly 102 to 136
million dollars
as such this is a highly regular
regulated fishery with a variety of laws
and rules designed to maintain a healthy
Lobster resource in a robust Fishery
this is not conducted in a vacuum we
work with the Atlantic states marine
fisheries Commission to um
to manage
Lobster American lobster through a
fisheries management plan so the other
states that have American lobster
fishery also have these rules and
regulations
while the lobster population in the Gulf
of Maine is not depleted and overfishing
is not occurring the Atlantic states
marine fisheries commissions 2020
Lobster stock assessment raised concerns
over reduced young of year recruitment
in recent years since 2012 recruitment
throughout much of the Gulf of Maine has
shown sustained low levels which could
translate to reduced stock in the
fishery in coming years
currently New Hampshire Law requires
that all Harvesters of lobsters in their
state in our state waters both
recreational and commercial use the same
method of harvest the lobster trap
every resident in New Hampshire can
purchase a license to harvest lobsters
in the state including recreational
Harvesters via the Open Access five trap
license I've actually seen people in
kayaks fishing traps recreationally
this legislation is not about providing
access to a user group for recreational
Harvest anyone with interest in
harvesting lobster for personal use can
obtain a recreational Lobster Harvest
license to harvest buy traps make it
uniform throughout the fishery
the department has four major concerns
about House Bill 442
it's a new Harvest method during a time
when there is a grease in the young of
the Year population and sustainability
of the lobster population in the Gulf of
Maine is in question
just to give you guys a heads up right
now the Atlantic states marine fisheries
commission is meeting
to discuss about a sustainability
issue with
American lobster and there will likely
be additional fishery management plan
regulations moving forward
four trap Harvesters
there's also climate degradation of
marine habitat warming Waters is the
main issue the increase in user
conflicts and enforcement concerns so I
have asked Colonel Jordan to sit next to
me to address those enforcement concerns
a little later
the lobster trap is a passive capture
device and rules have been implemented
regarding trap construction that
minimize their impact on the lobster
resource such as traps are required to
have a statements at a size to allow
Juvenile and sub-legal lobster to escape
it prevents excessive handling of
sub-legals they're not in the Trap when
they get pulled up the Harvesters are
just handling the legals for the most
part
the biodegradable Escape panels that are
designed to degrade over time to allow
escapement of lobster
if it traps our loss due to storms
um due to
other vessel traffic that cuts lines
those sort of issues arise with
loss of gear
while track Trap Fishing is a passive
form of capture for example the lobsters
crawl into the baited traps on their own
captured by scuba diving is an active
form that involves grabbing and at times
chasing
lean Lobster to capture it a lobster
will sometimes shed one or both claws
during this active form of capture in an
attempt to escape scuba divers will
encounter and handle numerous short
Underside lobsters for each legal size
Lobster they encounter and while
lobsters will eventually regenerate the
Lost clause
there is a cumulative short time loss
for desired Harvest from both the
recreational and the commercial
standpoint in addition newly molted soft
shell lobsters hide under rocks for
several weeks until their shells have
hardened and would be vulnerable to this
kind of handling which you have heard
from the diving community
a newly malted Lobster body is literally
softest Jello when handled could sustain
severe life-threading life-threatening
damage to its internal organs
I'd like to provide some insight as to
why we feel it is important for New
Hampshire to continue to limit Lobster
harvested traps only while our states to
the South do allow Harvest by other
message methods including scuba diving
we the states of Massachusetts and Rhode
Island are the two states that do allow
it
um ma'am if you could um
sort of give given a overview because we
have the we have the copy of the letter
in front of us so you don't need to read
the whole thing and in the interest of
time we do have one other person who's
asked to testify and so we will read
your letter if you could just cover the
Salient points that you'd like us to
know about thank you
um so essentially we'd like to limit the
Harvest of lobsters to trap to traps as
this is management measures that we have
rules and regulations that we understand
do conserve and maintain the
sustainability of
the lobster population thank you
and I'd like to turn it over to Colonel
Jordan for the enforcement aspect
so couple things uh well more than a
couple probably but I didn't bring the
bill so shame on you guys for bringing
it
so a couple things
um when we talk about access for
resource we've heard that a lot today
about people deserving access for
resource quite frankly we limit that on
everything we do I think everyone should
have access to shoot a moose if they so
desire but we don't allow for that I
think people should be allowed maybe to
chase a deer using using a drone we
don't allow for that we limit take and
opportunity regularly we do it it's our
regular course of business and we do it
in an effort to not to punish people but
to manage these resources and I'll let
the resources speak for how well that's
worked I think I'm very confident when I
sit here and tell you that we're doing a
good job because there's a lot of
resources the lobster industry is a 34
million dollar industry to New Hampshire
please don't mess that up that's a very
important amount of money coming into
the state of New Hampshire and the other
thing that I want to say about diving is
diving is allowed in two states not the
whole Eastern Seaboard two states for
American lobsters that would be Rhode
Island and Massachusetts I've talked to
the to the Chiefs in both those States
both regret allowing that and I know why
I could have answered that question
without a phone call to them because
they face the same challenges we do so
the issue becomes enforcement I
obviously can't put a diver down to
watch these guys taking
lobsters under the water so the argument
is made well how do you watch a lobster
fisherman doing it well we watch him
because we can literally see him take
those lobsters out of the ocean in the
Trap they caught it in I can then go up
and inspect the Trap we restrict and
regulate very strictly how that trap is
designed and what they're allowed to
take the size of the lobster I'm
literally watching that come out of the
ground out of the water the way it was
trapped I'm not going to see that and a
diver I've made three diving cases when
I worked down on the coast for a short
period of time illegal diving cases the
first case is one and and I will agree
with with representative Smith not
everybody is a criminal thank goodness
but I'm here to tell you I've been doing
this for 32 years and I haven't been
drinking coffee
so there is an element out there that
are going to cross that line whether we
like it or not they will and and an
invite they don't put out this crew
doesn't these types of people don't put
out dive Flags they don't announce
they're there they just go out and and
do their business and the first one that
I ever got I thought was incredibly
smart in that he brought up legal dot
legal lobsters a couple of them in a bag
and then he came up and I was with a
wise old Warden Who convinced me to wait
rather than go approach him and then we
watched him go back once he was sure the
coast was clear and he recovered the bag
of the big bag of illegal lobsters that
he had caught they're not going to come
up the first time with a bunch of
illegal lobsters they're not that dumb
they're going to come up and look around
and make sure that the ghost is clear
and then they're going to go back these
are the these are the way this is the
way that these some of these people no
one in this room none of these divers
behind me are going to be the problem I
can assure you they're they're
upstanding individuals I've met with
them we've talked about this but I
cannot disagree with a single fisherman
I'm begging you not to be naive enough
to think that a diver is not going to
raid a lobster troll they are absolutely
going to do that
those lobsters are there it's easy for
the picking and we're going to have some
who do that now the problem with that is
a lobster Fishman is going to complain
about that to me and I'm going to be
pretty powerless to prove it and when
you go into a core courtroom you got to
be able to prove where those lobsters
came from I've got to have evidence to
present to the judge other than a short
Lobster that's simple or or a bag
bearing Lobster I can do that but I'm
I'm going to be powerless my guys are
going to be powerless to do the method
of take there's just no way they're
going to be able to do that because I'm
not going to put them down in scuba
suits I can't do it I I don't have the
people to do that
um the the uh resource or the or the
argument that they don't have access to
the resource it's a forty dollar license
to buy a five trap I agree with shree
I've seen people out there in small
boats I don't know about you folks but I
buy dive equipment I do it pretty
regularly for my dive team I can assure
you it cost me in excess of forty
dollars I've got to certify those guys
the tanks and Regulators of 500 a dive
suit I just bought some there were
fourteen hundred dollars a piece I would
argue that it's probably cheaper to get
a lobster trap license than it would be
to die for them the other thing that was
mentioned was was guiding for lobsters I
want you to understand there is no
currently no regulations regarding dive
guides we don't regulate them in any
shape manner reform we do fishing guides
we do hunting guys we don't have
anything to do with with diving guides
so that's all things that we'd have to
look at and looking at the list in this
bill there's an awful lot of stuff that
has to be put into place in the 60 days
window that we've been given before the
law becomes effective all concerns of
mine my final concern is on page two and
I'm arguing or debating the the original
bill
uh page two starting at line four no
person shall at any time take any
Lobsters by any method except by hand
that is the worst way to do this you've
heard testimony by that it is the worst
way to take a lobster this law is
allowing that the way it's written and
then it goes on to say you can use a
tickle stick they'll be permitted but it
doesn't require that and if it did
require a tickle stick I'd be anxious to
find out from anyone in the room how I'd
enforce that how would I know if they
took it with a tickle stick you always
get people come up and testify to how
easy law enforcement would be in this
but remember one thing these are people
that have never done law enforcement
or they wouldn't be testifying like that
so I'd encourage you to ride with us
I'll show you how we do it what's
required any other method of take I can
witness with a spotting scope a set of
binoculars an undercover officer I can
watch it I'm not going to be able to
watch this this is going to happen under
the water and they're going to get away
with whatever they're doing under the
water and I I just and the final thing I
want to leave you with and I don't want
to insult anybody here but I've been
coming over here for 10 years this bill
has been back I think this is the sixth
time
when a bill comes back six times
and when a bill comes back and is
completely gutted with three different
amendments it's usually because the
first idea wasn't a very good one that's
my take on that I'd ask you to consider
that when you vote
thank you questions Mr Vice chair
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the questions
Colonel first I want to thank you for
answering the question I had which was
dealing with how you would determine
whether or not
an individual took a lobster by hand in
water that we heard from testimony
earlier that in New Hampshire on the
coast you can only see pretty much 10
feet in so I think that's pretty hard to
determine but my question goes to
on page one
line 27
can you tell me what the definition of
protected zone is
well that's undetermined I think I think
you could I think that opens it up for a
bunch of different things to happen I
think a predict I assumed and it's an
assumption but I assume the idea of that
was and I'll and I'll applaud the lot
the diving Community for trying to come
up with a way to negate some of the
arguments so I think they felt that if
we have zones where diving is allowed in
my opinion that would mean that
fishermen are not allowed again we have
a very small Coastline and a very and a
very important industry I think and
these poor guys are up against it at
every turn for multiple reasons and and
to restrict them further to me is not in
our best interest
follow
up
so without a definition of protected
zone is pretty hard to determine and
enforce yes it would be pretty I mean
we'd have to have we'd have to rehash a
definition of that for sure yes if I was
ever going to make a case on it because
the first thing a judge would ask me is
what is that I'd have to describe that
in detail and we'd have to Market we'd
have to maintain those boundaries so
that everybody knew that and that we
could present that in court if we ever
looked to convict anyone for violating
it
one last follow-up if I made follow-up
and on page two
line one
shall be within 100 yards of the
shoreline is that at the high water mark
low water mark or what is the definition
there yeah so that that could that could
vary the way it's written now that would
vary you'd have to have that spelled out
thank you yeah thank you
any other questions
Miss Clerk
thank you Colonel Jordan I always
appreciate yourself please don't take an
insult to that I know you wrote the
Amendments but I think it's important to
note that that's why they get written
nothing I've nothing I've written has
been touched on you all right all right
so
um I actually have a question for for
each of you if if that's all right my
first question is the enforcement piece
uh Colonel Jordan I understand that it's
the method to take would not be
enforceable
but the idea that there would be an
increase whereas there's there's no
enforceability currently for divers to
not you know coach traps or however else
whatever other issues might you might
suspect so where is the presumption or
why is there a presumption that that
activity would increase when we
currently have no way to enforce it I
think so I'll try to answer that as best
as I can I think some of that could be
answered by I don't know
there's a there's certainly the word is
out that they can't uh dive on lobster
traps so my experience has been divers
May dive in the area but they don't dive
over the traps because it's well known
that that's not allowed now I would
worry that that would go away if we were
to allow diving if we were allow diving
where there is lobster fishing I guess I
should say that would probably increase
and that would be a concern oh and the
other thing I wanted to add there was a
diving fatality I I specifically
remember it was in 2013 a diver went
down to recover his lost traps and
drowned passed away so there have been
diving accidents not many but there have
been some
you know follow up on it quick follow up
uh so that was his own lost job as a
okay yeah he was trying to recover his
own law strap and the other question is
very brief for uh Ms Patterson
um I believe we had had a conversation I
wanted to clarify the number 250
000 traps are lost per year in these
Waters is that what I remember from our
conversation no our conversation uh had
to do with whether I had any clear
numbers as to uh what ghost gear is out
there and there is a there was a study
done in the state of Maine where they
had 250 000 traps that they had
estimated to be lost of course the state
of Maine has a lot more traps than a 14
mile coastline
okay representative Brown
dummy Smith
thank you Mr chairman thank you Colonel
yes sir just to follow up from on the
enforcement side so I'm reading the
letter here and I do understand the best
case scenario for enforcement would be
to catch the guy grabbing a lobster
right that would also apply to deer
hunting or turkey best case scenario
absolutely but majority of time the fish
and game officer is not on site and it's
the actual completion of the
investigation or the enforcement part is
done through an investigative process to
get to that conviction of the guy
poaching yes and that would include uh
just remember that would include witness
testimony so someone else may have seen
it or evidence collected at the scene
which brings up another point that would
be non-existent underwater so in a in a
deer hunting case an illegal case we
follow blood Trails we follow tracks we
follow we pick up casings those are all
pieces of evidence to make that case
otherwise you won't make it in an
underwater situation you're not going to
get any of that you're not going to have
any of that and you're not going to have
any witness testimony or very limited
what I'm I'll tell you what I'm going to
get I'm going to get from and I don't
mind them hearing it I'm going to get
from these guys behind me they went into
my trap they won't know that they're
going to assume that and they're going
to put pressure on us to stop that and
I'm going to be powerless to do that I
don't know how I'd do that
uh other than guesswork and you can't
bring as you know you can't bring
guesswork into court it won't fly so
that's my concern that's one of my big
concerns
one follow-up for
and I'll be done very quick how many
lobsters on day are caught on average I
don't know it's not a question for the
colonel it's probably in the commercial
industry how many Lobster in a day I
couldn't I mean is it a thousand ten
thousand uh I'm in state waters yes I
would it would be in the thousands so
theoretically if this bill became law
this would allow a minimum of 300 if
there's 100 licenses and three with a
minimum so the numbers detrimental is
all I'm trying to show just bear in mind
that collecting them by hand could do a
lot more damage you may have them in
hand but that doesn't mean that that's
the only impact on the resource okay
just bear that in mind thank you thank
you for your testimony I'm going to cut
off the questions for this because we
have one more speaker and we've got a
hard stop at 115 when this room is going
to be used by Commerce
so I'm going to call Mike Flanagan
you asked for five minutes and if you
could please keep it under that I'd
appreciate it
um
good morning Mr chairman and committee
uh Mike Flanagan Ryan New Hampshire I'm
speaking on behalf of myself well myself
and my family
I used to be the young kid I'm the old
guy now I've been doing this for 67
years as my brother has been we both
have 1200 trap licenses my son's own a
wholesale off-site piece of waterfront
property in Kittery they do business
both Maine and New Hampshire fishermen
my whole family is deeply involved in
the lobster Fishery
I'm opposed to the bill for obvious
reasons about the skin diving thing I
couldn't understand the man that
proposed the bill what this thing is
about cutting funding from the wardens
in federal waters that's ridiculous I
couldn't understand his reason for it
can somebody explain to me why that was
brought up
I can tell you that's no longer a
concern and it's being brought out of
the bill according to the prime sponsor
it's it's not a requirement because uh
the delay in activating the federal
regulations that was put in for six
years has made it in ineffective
well my situation is anybody that knows
the situation would never bring that up
because the three mile limit between
state waters and area One Federal line
it's all over the place in New Hampshire
and most of us have Federal permits
it's utterly ridiculous we could be
fishing in state waters
and have something on the boat we didn't
want the wardens to cease we'd just jump
over the line say you can't touch me I'm
in federal waters now it's that should
never happen we need more enforcement
not less
a lot of things people brought up
I want a kind of a show and tell
situation I want to show you some of the
tools we use I don't want to be here all
day long people talked about ghost traps
this is a biodegradable Escape then
this is from the Federal Register we use
stainless steel rings on this end as a
hinge a steel ring on this end to
disintegrate
opens
supposed to be three and three quarter
inches this is four and a quarter inches
a huge Lobster will get out of there and
as Bill macaroni said these things do
work we have to maintain them all the
time and replace the steel rings
this is called a crab vent or a circular
vent two and seven sixteenths inches a
lot of lobsters come and go through that
another point I want to make I have a I
have a bird feeder outside my house most
of you people probably do and the
reality of it is our lobster traps our
Lobster feeders
we're required to have this vent where
we kind of this vent most of us have
several of these vents
this is a v-notch tool that we've Notch
the Tails of the female lobsters with
this is the measure we use to measure
them with
I was I've been here a long time
we fought this v-nots issue years ago
Maine came up with it we all thought it
was ridiculous now we all Notch and
there's a tremendous tremendous volume
of V notch lopsis in the resource the
lobster resource because of this is
extremely healthy but my point is
feeding the lobsters
there are photographs people had it
amazed me when I saw it how many lobs
have swarmed to the traps of all sizes
they swim in they swim out it's they're
just like the bird feeders at our house
I'd like to pass this around a few folks
who like to look at it any questions
about it or any other questions
thank you for your testimony I'll allow
the Reps to look at that on our way out
um does anybody have any questions real
quick
Adam clerk thank you did I thank you for
taking my question did I hear you
correctly just very brief yes or no that
the industry actually was very resistant
to previous regulations like the
requirement to v-notch for example but
then that regulation turned out to be an
actual good thing
I can say this now because I'm the
oldest one
we as Lobster fishermen are extremely
extremely resistant to change anything
we
there was tremendous opposition what
we've tried to do over the years
Connection in different states is to
have the same minimum size New Hampshire
was always smaller and there's a
tremendous amount of Bloodshed and
raising the lobster measure a tremendous
amount of Bloodshed adopting anything
from anybody else no matter what it is
we just like to be resistant that's
unfortunately the nature of the lobster
fisherman but it's worked out well
Maine New Hampshire Massachusetts all
had the same maximum size the same
minimum size the dealers could swap
lobsters back and forth among the states
it's working very well
thank you
any other real quick questions
not seeing any thank you for your
testimony thank you and that concludes
the hearing on hb442
I'll leave these on the corner of the
table and I'll wait a few minutes if you
folks want to stop and talk to somebody
but I want to apologize to the director
fishing game that we don't have enough
time to finish the discussion today but
we will pick up if you want to invite
anybody who hasn't spoken to us yet for
our next hearing which will be on the
Amendments it'll be a public hearing
with an exact session to follow
we do not have a date yet but it'll be
uh at least a week away
thank you